get one though i got a big one over here
okay so then we're good
okay all right we're live we're
officially live episode number 61 back
with tom and adam
and we got a lot to talk about the one
thing we are going to talk about today
is ufos
we have to talk about us a lot of crazy
things going on and there was a 60
minute done on ufos this last week marco
rubio
he thinks is the biggest crisis but we
got to address that part number two we
got to address
bill gates and melinda gates divorce
it's getting a little bit uh
interesting always a story every day
yeah there's something new
if he wanted to be in the media on the
news every day he's pulled it off he's
definitely pulled it off but there's a
conversation about how much money they
want to leave behind
and this is the first time we're during
the divorce you said melinda gates is
bringing in a what well she's bringing
in a state lawyer
an inheritance lawyer a divorce along
with her divorce attorney and that's not
common
not at all no very rare so we're going
to cover that there's a story talking
about during covet we didn't have enough
sex so adam said that's his top story
we're going to talk about that for sure
i think the world needs to know i think
we have to address it a-rod
and his friend by the timberwolve
timberwolves and then we have another
one that's talking about
uh basically tell us about this so
that's yeah so you know
uh so there was protests yesterday on
tax day
at bezos residences in new york city and
seattle
because these protesters you know want
these are actually millionaires and we
can get into this a little bit more but
they want the
ultra rich to pay a higher share so they
were protesting at some of bezos houses
yesterday millionaires protesting in
front of a billionaire saying he's not
paying enough taxes exactly that makes a
lot of sense that that makes a lot of
sense absolutely so
this past weekend there was a ufc fight
i don't know if
there was ufc was it 261 261 i believe
it was right 261 times
262. 262 and i'm sitting at the house
and friends are calling me telling me
you know this assyrian guy's is fighting
and i said the witch's syrian guys the
domain is
benil daryush daryush is uh in the
assyrian community they respect our you
salad but daryush is a persian name so
hey this guy's
you know he's been talking a lot about
the you know you got to take a look at
him so i've never seen him fight i've
only seen the highlights so then i see
him fight and he goes up against
can you pull up uh uh what he said at
the end of the fight i think he goes up
against
who's the guy he's going up against it's
a big fighter 37 year old who's
not at the best he was on a two uh fight
uh yeah it was the co-main event so it
was
what's his name went up against um
can somebody help me out here if you're
watching this somebody has to know who
it is who was he going up against he was
going up against
bernie sanders not bernie sanders book
but tony ferguson
and tony's a legendary fighter the guy's
abuse if you've seen this guy fight
before the guy's a
knockout artist just a rock star they
fight
assyrian daryush wins okay daniel wins
at the end of the fight rogan's
interviewing the guy in the middle of
the interview what do you typically say
you know i want to call out such and
such i want to go after this guy
i want to go after that guy he says this
at the end of his fight after he wins
i want to dedicate this fight to all the
people
who've been hurt by marxist ideologies
there are millions of you and i know it
and it's just a fight i know it's not
much but i want you to know that i love
you
and i understand the pain i don't
completely understand but i love you and
i
i understand your pain can you imagine
you use your platform to talk about that
yeah
coming from an assyrian who just want to
fight that's i think it's a
six seven match win streak or six match
win streak yeah it's amazing he has
faculties together at the end of that
fight to do that they they you they know
everybody's watching them
it's a forum for them to say what they
want you know joe rogan's going um
book him for my next podcast sounds
really interesting you know what else he
said
what's that he called out elon musk so
he literally did this kind of
you can pull that up too so after he did
the message about marxism destroying the
world and feeling the pain of everybody
that's under the influence of that
he he called out elon musk because the
delivery of his wife's car
is late late and he's got a daughter on
the way and he wants her protected and
elon actually responded to that
so you can see these guys probably in
the middle of the match they're thinking
all right
i got to get this win so i could have
this huge political message
thank the right people most of them are
setting up their next fight i guarantee
on the next one you're going to hear the
words jake paul
start creeping into the ufc well you
heard it again this time
that that name is being dropped
everywhere now even cormier is like
cormier said
you hear what they're saying i don't
even want to repeat what name they're
saying but they're saying the name that
i know they're saying everybody
but i think it's going to start turning
to a little bit more positive i think
they will eventually
embrace jake paul and everything that he
can bring to them and i think some of
those lower level
ufc fighters will be sanctioned to fight
him by dana white
interesting so i have a different
perspective on this number one i'm just
going to start out in saying
fyi dana white just to stop real quick
dana white
just stopped the possibility of gsp
uh fighting uh against de la hoya and de
la hoya upped
the the purse saying i'll give you
another quarter million dollars if
you're willing to fight me dana's like
nah that's not gonna be happening
because i think he's saving him for a
big fight against khabib
i think something very big is coming up
with ufc a fight
very big versus boxers de la hoya no no
no no i'm talking purely ufc i think
okay
i think dana's up to something and he's
about to launch a very big fight but the
boxers just take everything from him
because
well a he runs the whole you know if it
wasn't for him
i mean my god boxing would be dead
there'd be no ufc but i think he could
flip over if it weren't for who dana
white
dana white and if he's someone for him
boxing would be dead no if it wasn't for
dana white
we'd have no combat sports daniel
white's helped that boxing and ufc
how has he helped out boxing are you
kidding me what happened with the with
the counter fight against mayweather
what happens to a lot of these boxing
fights
did he arrange that that was his deal he
didn't arrange that but if he didn't
create a platform where he promotes the
way he did to
to give birth to conor mcgregor who goes
from being on welfare to not being worth
a few hundred million dollars
to being one of the biggest box office
fights hey that that credit goes to the
promoter big part of the credit goes to
the promoter and that's dana white
clearly um he's dominated with the ufc i
just didn't understand the
the how it carries over to boxing you're
saying a rising tide lifts all ships
ufc's lifting shows boxing if you ask me
yeah
i think he's helped because it's a
rising sh you know the whole rising
tide left all the ships but i tell you
they're dominating right now yeah
there's a no but
i have i have not ordered a fight in a
long time
a fight like meaning boxing if i do it
have to be a big one i don't order the
boxing fights
ufc's it's like a regular thing i think
it's this
as ridiculous as it sounds i think it's
the paul brothers that are actually
making boxing relevant again
since floyd retired what does that tell
you though what is that
that there needs to be some some some
action on the boxing ring
there needs to be a don king coming in
the mix like a dana white
to make boxing excited again dana white
is the face of ufc yeah
who's the face of boxing good luck
finding dana white oscar de la hoya try
to do it oscar's not dana white
to be a promoter it's not everybody's
job i once interviewed wayne demilia one
of the greatest bodybuilding promoters
of all time this guy would show up in a
camel
to with he would bring a bodybuilder on
a camel
in a show just because he wanted so he
was a massive promoter
you can every industry every sport that
ever did great
you will find a great promoter behind
closed doors wwe every single mcmahon
every single game had a great promoter
dana happens to be one of the best if
not the best of all so why can't they
figure it out in boxing
like corruption is it it's been just a
corrupt sport and i think political
they don't know how to promote it here's
the other thing i mean dana white is so
powerful
so influential right now he's the main
reason i think that endeavor william
morris was able to get their ipo
because they they brought in the private
investors to totally bring the
the ufc into the fold and that allowed
them to go public after failing in 2019
and it's the most valuable commodity
with with endeavor and william morris
the stock started at 24 it's moving its
way up that thing's only getting bigger
but you know what
jake paul has started a dialogue that
the box or that the ufc fighters are
underpaid
and it's going to be a huge thorn in
dana white's side
follow this he went off on it the other
night he's like the champion for ufc
fighters saying you're the ones putting
your life on the line
risking your health and your injuries
and you're not getting paid you know
that's pissing off dana white big time
that's nothing new though that's been
said for a long time that's been that's
been said about dana for 15 years but
he's got a big bullhorn and people are
actually hearing it because jake paul's
got a following
yeah i i by the way i agree with you i
think there's things going on over there
where he's not paying the guys as much
as they are to him his opinion is more
from the place of
at least these guys were making nothing
now they're making this they were they
were coming off the streets and they're
not professional boxers they're street
fighters now they're making this
but i do think that can hurt him long
term i just i just think it's a story
that he's been able to deflect for a
very long time
well it's like you're believing the
power of competition if you have who's
ufc's competitor bellator is it bellator
i've never even heard of that that's my
point is i've never ordered
so if so if someone if a conor mcgregor
or khabib or you pick a name cormier
whoever
he's like i don't know i'm done with
this [ __ ] you're not paying me now go
ahead i'm going to belladore all right
good luck at bellator buddy i've never
even heard of it see what kind of a show
that's the problem with competition is
that yeah they might be paying their
fighters
less than market value but the market
creates the value if there's no place to
go i'm with
dana white it's the sport that is the
number one it's the it's the spectacle
it's the show
jake paul said one of the ring girls was
actually paid more than one of the
fighters
on the last card see that's the kind of
the thing she must have been hot though
the thing with jake paul the thing with
jake paul is that he's a professional
troll he's a professional troll
he's even a better troll than his
brother is logan's not a troll
jake is a troll true jake i would say
jake is heroes probably
probably takashi six nine maybe trump if
i were to tell you
who jake models his game after it has to
be takashi six nine
not even trump it has to be takata he's
face time with trump no
he did i know but what i'm trying to
tell you with the cops trump was a
billionaire
trolling people he was at the top
trolling people takashi came from
nowhere to being everybody says i can't
believe this guy's alive this guy's
alive
how's takashi still alive going out
there saying what he's saying right the
other day
he posted something on instagram saying
here's a gofundme account for this guy
go help him
buy little you know uh lemon because he
needs a card
he's a professional and he literally
looks like a troll and and jake
is duplicating what does that have
what are the long-term consequences of
being a freaking troll
like short-term yeah people you're on
the news you get rich
you're in the news okay let me ask you
long-term you're gonna be the most
go back who are the biggest trolls and
how how did it turn out for them
how did it turn out well if it's takashi
6'9 you do a little time in jail
no no no what i'm saying is go back okay
go back to the 70s
80s so for example morton downey jr was
one of the biggest trolls okay
for him pull up his uh
okay in the 80s and early 90s i don't
know what the exact year was
morton downey jr for 18 months took over
jerry took over montel williams took
over oprah winfrey
took over everybody he was it he would
smoke
cigarettes get in people's faces curse
him out on national television
and he brought ron paul he brought
everybody on morton downey jr kai
can you pull that up something something
that comes to mind is uh
uh charlie sheen when his tiger blood
days of the early 2000s when he's i
think that's drugs though that's that's
okay but he was trolling people whether
you're on drugs or not i've done this
guy
that's more than down to june is your
point is your point here ultimately it
doesn't last long
i i don't know that's what i'm trying to
find out with you
by the way you know what happened to
them the challenge with trolls is the
following here's a challenge with trolls
eventually if you have nothing of
substance to show for it the audience
goes for the next
troll trolls are seasonal people leave
you
in a heartbeat if you have nothing new
to troll so for example
if there's nothing new for jake paul to
troll what's gonna happen now if he can
last it for five ten years and produce a
few hundred million followers
he is a very relevant person at 35 now
he's got a family he's got maybe living
a different life he may have a different
opinion the whole story with these
trolls
is if you win or not meaning if takashi
69 comes out and has a banger album and
he's the number one on the charts that
actually makes good music all right it's
hard to argue against that
if jake paul actually goes 4-0 5-0 10-0
but once his ass gets knocked down he's
irrelevant
control true sure i wouldn't say he was
a
troll i think he was i think he ruffled
some feathers and he was just a straight
gang
so let's define what a troll is what is
a troll
an instigator you know again what is a
troll i think there's two types of
trolls i think there's the troll that
actually
is is kind of has some beef and that
they're they're putting out there and
they it's
like tupac and then there's a troll in
harmony oh
i mean the best we're not against rap
well we are against
rappers he called out pushing against
the i guess my point is you're pushing
against the system you have a point to
make you actually do have some substance
some value
versus just being a [ __ ] talker annoying
troll
just for the point of being annoying
that's what i think jake paul is
you think jake paul is annoying is what
you're saying i think the the stat show
he's probably the most hated man in
america right now
we can ask ask our audience but now what
you're saying is jake paul is an
annoying
troll that's what you're saying but he's
still a troll and once he gets his ass
knocked out and loses
you tell me a troll in the history of
trolls that didn't annoy
somebody that wasn't annoying to
somebody
so that's part of their dna but jake
paul happens to be
your annoying troll not mine i don't you
can i tell the truth about adam's
computer here it is okay
when adam next to the notebook when it
goes what do you call it when the
computer screen uh uh
screen saver screen saver it's jake
paul's picture he's got uh
i don't understand why you do that to
yourself i know he wants to fight him
you know jake paul has monetized his
trolling that's that's what he's been
able to do in the big
give him respect on that and you see i
disagree i don't think he has to win his
fights because
he's smart enough to always pick a fight
with the baddest dude on the block
so he's not trolling wimps he's the
baddest dude on the block floyd
mayweather
uh conor mcgregor but he hasn't fought
these people yeah but he's trolling them
he's instigating it he's doing it right
now he's getting the attention
plus i will say this the dude is
influential i'm not a huge fan
but i know the influence he has because
i drove to his house probably eight
times because dash was a fan of him
four or five years ago when he was
cranking up
history has had plenty of trolls it's
not this is not a new playbook
pablo escobar i just went to a website
that says list the top 25 trolls pablo
escobar
was on the list of trolls he was a troll
uh let me see what else we got here on
this list that i'm looking at the uh
countries have been trolled andy warhol
was a troll artists are trolls
is a troll edgar allen poe machiavelli
was a troll
uk's been a troll ben franklin troll
there's a
pen and teller for many different
reasons it's taking shot
elon musk is the biggest troll right now
in the world that's true
he's deciding what happens to the crypto
i mean look what's been happening to
those guys
one minute he sells okay no this is the
greatest thing we're gonna get
you know elon musk you know we're gonna
buy one and a half million billion
dollars of uh uh bitcoin
right then they make nearly uh half a
billion dollars
it was a trillion dollar you know it was
a billion dollars then they made a half
a billion dollars
and then he says we're selling we're no
longer accepting bitcoin then he says to
cnbc yesterday
he says to cnbc yesterday i never said
we sold we still have the bitcoin
and then bitcoin drops from whatever
64th out to 4243 dow
market's going crazy then it's
complementing doge saying i'm working
with the technology
but he was on snl the other day
basically trashing doge and making fun
of it
single-handedly yeah he's influencing a
trillion
dollar trillion dollar product he's
influencing think about the amount of
influence he has
think about the amount of influence this
guy has well did you see peter schiff's
whole take on this do you think peter
schiff's got a pretty good take on on
the financial system
i think peter schiff doesn't give
crypto enough credit as he ought to and
i think he's taking a different position
on it
he does bill maher does uh a lot of
different people do
many buffett and also our friend bill
gates not exactly
what do all of them have in common they
old as [ __ ] that's there you go
not not as [ __ ] because [ __ ] shift is
not that old no i didn't say it
you said oldest [ __ ] they're all this
[ __ ] yeah that's what you said yeah
no no so the point is the point is
sometimes you're sitting there and
you're like oh my gosh what does this
kid know what he's talking about do you
realize i'm 72 years old
you realize what i've done in my life
and how many different investments we've
done but every once in a while
that kid could be the next you you
forgot you were 22
and you went up against somebody and you
ended up being right just like this kid
may be right against you
it just so happens that the tables have
turned but the other thing too is these
guys the older people that have their
opinion they like being rich they're not
opposed to making more money and maybe
embracing something new so maybe
they're on to something too but you
couldn't have two more diversion forces
between the people that don't like it
and the people that are behind it and
are loyal to it and staying within
the crypto scene well tell me if you
agree with this i'll read the peter
schiff quote that i reference he says if
a single elon musk tweet
can have so much influence over the
price of bitcoin how can anyone
seriously consider it money how can
bitcoin be a safe haven
asset if a one-word tweet from elon
puts it at risk it should be clear by
now that buying bitcoin is gambling not
investing first and i took the tweet and
i put a poll out
to the audience seventy percent agree
thirty percent saying
no yeah chef's wrong that's okay fine
just like you say criticism
audience you say that right and this is
an audience that typically agrees with
bitcoin though but it's your audience
but here here's the thing to be thinking
about with what he just said right there
if if elon musk can go out there and say
something in bitcoin and it
changes the market the way it does it's
not the currency
it's the individual meaning if trump
went out there
and said go download rumble and 50
million people download it
oh my gosh rumble must be not real if a
you know bernie sanders goes up there
and says amazon is ripping people
off you ought to go protest and 200 000
people show up to protest
oh my god amazon must be weak no it's
called an influential person
with a lot of influence at the level of
ilan i don't know what his number is
right now 48 million followers 45
million followers
elon can say anything he's going to get
attention it's very simple
a a college professor with three phds
and
four masters who's got 2200 followers
can go tweet something and nobody even
knows what he's talking including his
kids
are probably not following his tweet so
that's called have an influence so
if peter's upset about having influence
you got to give the guy influence
credit now what elon is doing that
concerns me
is um i
i i i just don't know if the market and
i brought this up many times
i just don't know if the market's gonna
allow a guy to have that kind of power
and that kind of influence long term
i don't see that you know he's there's a
double whammy with elon unlike most
people where he can do whatever he wants
on social media and he's got this huge
following and he just moves the market
unbelievable and then the media is just
as much of
fanboys as his followers everything he
does
immediately is brought out in every
single media platform
unlike a donald trump where yes he was
covered in the media but negatively 100
negatively almost all the time
so here's the thing he is a professional
troll elon so how much
validity can we put into what he's
saying because he might just be having
fun
because he's so rich effing with people
and knowing that he can wake up in the
morning do one tweet and have the whole
world react
this could be sport for him who knows
right that's why i don't put too much
stock in what elon musk is saying
about cryptocurrency yet so you when
he's tweet something you're not buying
them
i'm not i'm not buying doge when he says
those from the moon although doge i
might jump in on because mark cuban's
behind it and it's cheap
kai just put 10 grand in on doge kai did
you or he's being sarcastic
no he's a believer he is it is what it
is i just want to make sure he was awake
over there just you know
he's on the scene he's paying attention
he's paying attention to the dogecoin
to see how it's doing right now but so
so going back to this if you're watching
this if you're watching this i'm curious
who do you think is the current modern
day best
troll in the world who do you think it
is i'm actually curious because i'm
looking at some of this stuff people are
saying jake jake jake
musk all these different names who do
you think is the biggest troll we have
in the marketplace today anyways
here's a story of bitcoin since we're
already talking about elon musk page
four
bitcoin exposed stocks slide alongside
the cryptocurrencies elon musk once
again wrecks havoc
wreaks havoc with a tweet this is a cnbc
story companies exposed to bitcoin slit
on monday in the wake of cryptocurrency
plunging to its lowest level since
february after elon musk suggested tesla
might have sold
its holdings over the weekend bitcoin
tumbled to 42 000 on monday
several hours after musk replied indeed
to a twitter post saying bitcoiners are
going to
slap themselves next quarter when they
find out tesla dumped the rest of the
bitcoin holdings
indeed the price of cryptocurrency
climbed
somewhat when the billionaire clarified
that tesla still holds at stake
elon musk may uh elon musk's may 13
reversal on allowing tesla to accept
bitcoin
as the payment shockwaves musk's twitter
announcement says tesla has suspended
vehicles purchasing using bitcoin
just came three months after the company
invested billions in the crypto
except it's as a payment for its
electric cars but you know again for me
if he's sitting there doing this
this is manipulation you can't do that
you can tell your opinion you can
you can say your opinion about what you
think doge is what you think
uh bitcoin is but to say
bitcoiner slapped themselves next
quarter when they found that tesla
dumped the rest of the bitcoin holdings
you say indeed what does that mean you
know i do feel like everybody is a pawn
underneath and it's a game i really
think it's a game to elon
i do he loved going on saturday night
live to tweet people for this
exact same do you think the government's
going to let him do that i don't think
sec is going to allow him to do that
i think they're going to crack down on
him eventually look at the numbers
bitcoin at 43k
down from a high of 65k in mid april
dogecoin 48 cents down from 75 cents
even um coinbase right they they've
plummeted since they're they're now
below 30 yeah i'm leery
of the people that are so outspoken and
so
adamant and passionate about it mark
cuban elon robert kiyosaki some of these
people
because they're very high profile how
much are they protecting their own brand
and doing it for credibility yeah
because they can't afford to look stupid
i have to tell you this
i have to tell you this here's a
challenge they're phrasing as well you
ready
say you got 10 million dollars of gold
say you got five million dollars of gold
so you got a million dollars of gold so
you got 50 million dollars of gold
if you do are you really gonna pump up
bitcoin
against uh gold and your investments i
don't know about that
shift is a gold standard guy you know
kyosaki is a gold guy yeah
okay silver yeah silver and you even
buff it buffett's not a bitcoin guy
buffett's
more you know silver you know he's got a
little bit of you're investing
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is there's a part of it also where
people
are telling like for example i own a
zion williamson card probably the best
card he has
i own one of them there's five of them i
have one of them okay
this is probably a million dollar card
okay what do you think i'm rooting for
when i watch a
zion play you think i'm not sitting
there saying i hope the score
this guy scores 56 points goes to the
playoffs does something i hate to make
it to the playoffs
tom injured all this stuff i'm telling
you publicly i am supporting
zion to have a killer career because i'm
banking on it that's my motive
i feel zion could be a player so the
investors the people out there have to
know when somebody makes an opinion
about something go a little bit lower
and find out where they're invested in
and then find out when a guy gets up
there and says
this is the greatest time to buy real
estate who says that
a guy a real not a realtor exactly when
a guy says
don't worry stay in the market
it's going to be all right don't sell
stay
good times are coming who's saying that
exactly so you have to also sit there
when somebody gives you the feedback
you have to go to a platform where
there's differing opinions
and see the debate going on yeah but at
the end of the day people are typically
going to give you what they think is the
you know what their main capitals in so
anyways that's why
when you think shift and some of these
guys there's a there's a motive behind
it
one thing nothing negative it's just it
is how we are one thing
look the everything with crypto bitcoin
dogecoin coinbase
has come to a screeching halt and has
gone down significantly since elon's
uh snl appearance he came on there and
since the opening monologue when his mom
showed up on mother's day
and he's like i got you something for
mother's day mom she goes please tell me
it's not doge going it goes it's
dogecoin yeah and then went on and on
and on and basically
called it a essentially a a scheme
not not a scam a scheme a side hustle
a hustle he's like oh it's a hustle
michael che asked him yeah it's a hustle
it's comforting right
i mean for the guy that's that
influential just joke about it follow
the money
look where it's gone um so ever since
his appearance
uh it has gone down so something that's
also come to the forefront which i
actually appreciate is like
things are coming out there the good the
bad the ugly everything the negative the
positive
something that doesn't necessarily
coalesce with his
whole views on life and his business is
the amount of
energy that it takes to mine bitcoin
that's like the one
big thing that's coming out there it's
like yeah it's digital currency yeah
and it's built on the blockchain and all
these good things about it but it's like
yeah
do you realize how much energy it takes
it takes
i i showed you the bill mark can you
pull that up i mean how much energy it
takes to minor
it's crazy bill maher who is obviously
not a fan of crypto he came out against
it draws line in the sand and basically
said
this takes a [ __ ] load of energy so you
can't be
pro-environment and pro-bitcoin all in
the same
uh uniformity right there because it's
sort of it's an oxymoron because it
takes so much energy
yet you know you if you're pro
environment and you know green new deal
and you're also cryptoed out it doesn't
necess uh
add up so here yeah you can't be more
contradictory than to have
a car company right to get away from
fossil fuels and then you're all into
this other thing that's why i think he's
effing with everybody i really do i
think this is sport for him what does he
have to lose he's worth 180 billion
this is fun how else is he gonna get any
fun he can't go anywhere
he can't do anything he goes anywhere he
gets mobbed right i think this is his
sport
something to keep in mind about elon
musk is if you go back
pre-pandemic even during like a year ago
from now do you know his net worth a
year ago
probably under 100. oh dude it was like
40. it was like 40 billion
and now he's at over 130 billion where
is he now i don't know his exact net
worth
but to go there's it that's a different
level number four now he dropped
number four but the point is to go from
30 40 billion to a hundred and thirty
like the guys
added a 100 saying what's your point
don't you think your perspective
and and your maybe your god complex will
change a little bit when you have
another 100 billion to your net worth
don't you think
things might change just a little from
your perspective
i i don't uh i don't disagree i think
there could be something happening there
you know the other day i was tweeting
about
how much it cost to uh make a penny it's
2.2 cents to make a penny right
i don't know if you know that's that it
cost 2.2 cents to make 217
2.06 to make a penny it makes no sense
it cost uh the federal reserve
five and a half cents to produce every
dollar bill five and a half cents to
produce every dollar bill and here's the
kicker
how many hands does a dollar bill or a
five dollar bill exchange in a year
let me say that one more time how many
hands what do you think a thousand
a dollar or a five dollar bill i'm
actually curious to know what the
viewers will say how many hands do you
think a dollar bill
or a five dollar bill in a year put me
down for a thousand you think a thousand
people will touch the dollar bill or
five dollar bill what do you think the
number is
five thousand it's actually really
interesting number it's 110
110 110 people it's great i was waiting
well maybe your dollar
went to too many strip clubs so they
changed way too many but there's a lot
of strip clubs there's other body parts
that that touch too unfortunately yeah
but the but the so i'm usually the rated
r guy you got a
two pg-13 guys going out so so i have
richard uh who they keep telling me that
i got to get this guy on our heart who
responds and says
do you know it costs 40 000 to mine a
bitcoin i don't know if it's true or not
he says it can you type in how much does
it cost to mine a bitcoin
he says forty thousand dollars to minor
bitcoin
if it costs forty thousand dollars to
mine a bitcoin are you
kidding me like so someone that's not
sustainable it's not
about sustainable you know we lump him
into this category with the
one-dimensional
nerds billionaires the guys that have
created something and that they're hyper
focused on
technology or building a company like
that in my opinion i think elon
is 65 business genius 35
entertainer i really do he's his wife
he's or his mom was a supermodel
you know on the cover of vogue you know
i think he is an
entertainer almost as much as he is a
business tycoon
a tech genius etc so some of this is
sport for him
he gets more amusement out of this than
anybody else with a high net worth so i
just find
forbes article kai i don't know if
you're looking at the forbes article i
put okay
right there go right there it says pull
up and press control plus to make it
bigger so the audience can see it
and can we flip on the camera so the
audience can see it as well
okay if you go there and take a look it
says
in early 2020 researchers predicted the
cost to mine bitcoin will be around can
you get rid of
okay we'll be around twelve thousand
dollars or fifteen thousand dollars
after the block reward how
how howling in may mention it half like
split split
but it is now much cheaper to mine
bitcoin btc than the initial estimates
the low breakdown price to mine bitcoin
may leave its vulnerable to correction
uh
go go little lower i saw five to six
thousand dollars go a little lower see
what else we have on the bottom
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going okay so so i
you know again 12 to 50 right there
with you know miners based in china said
that the breakdown break-even cost to
mine bitcoin hovers around five to six
thousand dollars
the break even costs around five to six
thousand dollars considering the cost of
mine bitcoin for the big mining centers
individuals miners can range
five to eight thousand dollars miners
have more incentive to sell to cover
operational costs
rather than to hold on to the btc they
mine so five to
five to eighty five hundred dollars to
my bitcoin here's the kicker he said
forty thousand
right let's say he's right it used to be
forty thousand to mine a bitcoin
then it went down to twelve thousand
twelve to fifteen thousand dollars and
it goes to five to eighty five thousand
dollars
i think they're gonna find cheaper ways
to mine bitcoin long term regardless of
it that's pretty expensive
to mine a bitcoin what do you think
about that
i'm going to ask a question that i i
assume half our audience is thinking
how the hell do you mine a bitcoin i get
it it's not mining like a gold digger
yeah
you're figuring out computer algorithms
where'd you go
with the gold digger comment where are
we going with that i was going to go
somewhere the stripper stuff
no no take it out there but the the one
thing that i
actually appreciate and if you guys
haven't seen bill maher's take on
cryptocurrency it's actually
a pretty impressive one whether you
agree with him or don't disagree
actually he goes
i've read articles about about crypto
i've done research on bitcoin and i
don't understand it
and neither do you and especially when
it comes to mining
so unless you're living this kind of
life like my buddy adrian lives in this
world and
i'm like how the bebop is doing and the
bitty bops and the bitcoins and the
bitty boos
people don't understand this i i know
many people have jumped in on the crypto
craze
and have no clue what they're doing by
the way i don't think you're wrong i
think a lot of people would agree with
you i think a lot of people are clueless
and they're acting like they know and
they simply have no clue what's going on
yeah
a lot of people are gonna look like
idiots that are self-proclaimed experts
on this right now and are
so loud and so adamant about it because
there's a good chance that this whole
world changes in a few months when it
comes to criminals you you underestimate
the power of idiots looking like
geniuses
i mean you you you you have to realize
there's a lot of idiots in the world
that stuck around and they were patient
banking on what's going to happen long
term and next thing you know
they're living in that 10 million home
driving a nice car and 15 million in the
bank and you're asking how did you make
your money
i simply went into doge i went into
crypto i went into bitcoin i went to
ethereum there are people like that out
there
there's something's got to be said
though about putting in
actual work there's a lot of bitcoin
millionaires out there who you know
kudos to them i'm not talking [ __ ]
that weren't working that hard and you
know heard you know they were dealing
stuff on the dark web and in the black
markets
and they heard about this and they kind
of lucked out yeah with where bitcoin
goes
at the end of the day i think a lot of
people just don't want to work that hard
and they want to get crypto rich
and i think that's going to be very ugly
for a lot of people who just want to get
rich quick and don't want to put in the
work well you got crypto rich
no well your last not how i got rich no
no no no no no that's not how you got
rich i'm not saying that but you
experienced a moment of crypto rich in
the last 90 days yeah i did
kind of an interesting thing yeah that's
your account on your account yeah how
much
it's a good amount of money right that
you're millions millions right and it's
like what the hell just happened yeah
now i owe money somehow
he's got to go mine it i just had 5
million
[Music]
electricity we're getting complaints i
invested in this
nft platform and i couldn't even spell
nft at the time but the guy's like oh
it's a good idea you got to do it but
so i think there's a lot of people look
at the end of the day with crypto you
can't
don't invest money you can't afford to
lose i think a lot of people want to get
rich quick
and they're in on this crypto scheme or
scam or or hustle whatever you want to
call it
or if it's legit whatever you want to
view it but this is not work
by the way shout out to chad williams
he's driving and listening to the
podcast had nice words to say
uh while he's listening to the podcast
chad appreciate the 50 bucks but i'm
gonna tell you guys a guy right here
just said something saying
ripple xrp is in a lawsuit with sec
could be the first crypto regulated 99
of cryptos will disappear they are also
in the crypto climate accord so here's
what it means if
one of them gets regulated
they can use the same case it is so
important for the crypto community
to make sure ripple wins it is just as
important for competitors to make sure
ripple wins as it is for them to because
if they lose
who they can go after how familiar are
you with this ripple xrp
as far as what just in general what what
it's what it is the business
i'm not i'm not so i have two different
perspectives here i have one friend
ricky spoke to him he's in australia the
criminal defense attorney
this guy's like the biggest he is the
biggest advocate
for ripple out there again he's an
attorney he doesn't he's not a crypto
guy
um but all he talks you're in on ripple
yet
xrp and then i talked to my buddy adrian
who's like dude don't touch that with a
10-foot pole
it's outdated it's not gonna work it's
there's lawsuits
so again it comes down to perspective
who's right who's wrong i don't know
you know it remains to be seen but it's
speculative
it's not a translation adam hasn't made
any money on it yet
that's not true but that's tough we're
not trading
twenty two hundred dollars in the last
three years on crypto
you can't you can't that's real money
right there okay so
there's a couple of zeros behind it he's
brewing
still haven't gotten go ahead oh there's
a six-month lock-up period that's
whatever that is yeah six-month lock-up
that sucks yeah well i mean it is what
it is so let's let's talk about a little
bit more of a serious topic that
everyone's being affected by and this is
something i want everyone's attention on
because
odds are there is somebody right now
that's going through
some kind of anxiety based on this story
and it's a cnn story talking about
why sexual activity took a pandemic hit
and what to do about it
if you're in that community this is very
important now why would cnn write an
article like this because it's cnn okay
in the age of covet 19 our sexual stock
has plummeted
none of the old excuses like working
late dinner obligations a rough commute
to get in the way
and with nothing else to do on a friday
night why not sex
our libidos are like the stock market at
a high level they go up or they go down
but when they
when you look closely there are numerous
factors
physical and psychological affecting
those fluctuations and the age of
covid19
we're exercising less eating more
drinking and smoking and vaping to
escape the anxiety all of which affect
our sexual health and self-esteem
we might not change out of our pajamas
or showers regularly which affects
attraction for largely shut off from the
outside world and it's external stimuli
stimuli and more on top of each other
than ever before
and that's leading to anger resentment
and sense of relational
claustrophobia our research even found
that the effects of force prolong
cohabitation
during the lockdown led partners to turn
to masturbation and porn use
and less to sex with each other what a
what a very
family-friendly article i mean it really
gets me you wanted to well
based on your your tone right there half
our audience has just drove upside there
there
they might go have sex right now that's
exactly what it is
we lose like a thousand people
everyone's having sex did you know that
you used the word sex in stock in the
same story there so adam i turn it over
to you your two favorites
save that money yeah well i think maybe
it's like saved.com yeah is that what it
is but go ahead
i don't think anyone's worried about
condoms these days they're worried about
covet i don't think anyone's worried i
think so
i think there's a bigger concerns out
there than uh
you know wrapping up um but i don't know
there's something about a pandemic cnn
tells me there's something legit going
on sienna writes it you gotta take it
seriously i do
uh there's something about a pandemic
uh that don't make me horny baby i i
don't know like
to use uh austin powers here don't make
you horny baby
uh no covet you don't however to give a
shout out to elon musk again the biggest
troll out there there we go i hope
everybody is ready for a [ __ ] summer
thing's about to get real [ __ ] around
here all right so
cover your eardrums you're familiar with
this [ __ ] summer effect
there's so much pent-up demand whether
you agree with this article or not
i guess people aren't having the sex at
times uh as much as they should
or could have yeah uh and now there's a
lot of pent-up demand
uh going on this summer and uh i've
experienced this for
experiences first hand down in south
beach people have been uh
and you're talking to a girl has any
girl asked you have you been vaccinated
has any girl asked you any questions
like that when you're talking to her has
anything about kovitt come up pre you
know
not not like all right i'm about to have
sex with you but have you been
vaccinated have you ever covered it yet
i think it's just
but how you have it as anything have you
ever covered yet
i think everyone i think everyone asked
each other that no no
i'm talking random you're talking to
i've been married for too long
for a long time i don't know what it is
to be single i don't know the games i
don't know
definitely um i'm actually gonna work
during the pandemic you're about to have
a baby in about three weeks you're
having a covet baby yeah so clearly this
article doesn't apply to you so maybe
you're uh
maybe this covert things turn the pbd on
it's kicking more than any
other kid we've had that's kicking this
kid is a kicking baby she's fired up to
come out
well but but going back to it when you
are i'm asking you i'm sick
i'm married he's married you're single
when you're out there in the market
you're talking to folks you're on yeah i
mean i've see
you you're what you're on you're on no
i'm on real life now
i'm unreal not on tv you grind it you're
all right just grinder at this point
got it so not so much for sex i'm just
looking for a guy to take care of me
whatever you're on i hear all these apps
from all you guys here that talk
i'm not on any apps i'm not sure i'm on
i'm on real life
south beach lifestyle when you're
talking to a girl is it coming up at all
is what coming up colbit it's anything
because it's coming up all right is it
is it coming out another question
is anything coming up where kai you're
out there in the market are girls asking
about covet
is that coming up i don't call it it's
not i've not had
that hey paul
when a girl actually talks to you
when you have the courage to talk back
what do you say i've had two and a half
women
ask me questions shame on you for saying
that's your real dog
i don't i don't think it helps you out
here's what i will say here's what i
will say
this is again in florida so there's
other states like
if you're in new york new jersey or
california you're gonna be like bro i
haven't been at a bar or a club in
a year and a half people are out and
about
people are out and about they're living
their best life they're in clubs they're
in bars they're in restaurants
again this is in florida and people are
mingling again
people ain't scared at this point i
think young people specifically buy this
do you buy this article
okay here's what okay go ahead you know
have you guys watched cnn lately or read
their stories there is no more group of
sexually suppressed people
than people that work for students
that's what i'm the ones i don't get any
sex so they're writing about it so they
they need to have a little bit more sex
and loosen up
but you know what if you google you're
saying liberals aren't banging
i'm talking about he's saying you ought
to go work for cnn it would be a lot of
uh
would that help my sexual activity or
we'll actually give an endorsement for
you
can i ask you a question yeah all right
as long as it's not it works
meaning he's going to ask me
how many times
i'm just saying has there been more
less or about the same romanticism in
your relationship over the last year
this isn't that personal just like
everything else it's whatever i say
there's going to be
damn i'm kidding tom yeah tom okay
but in general is it because you've been
unlocked in california is it the
same more less man i don't let pandemics
or anything being expressed
man okay okay but are divorces going up
are they the same where divorce is these
days that's a very good question i feel
like a lot of people are like dude i've
been
but i tell you you know what
if numbers there's a couple of guys that
went through this guy named jeff and
this kind of bill i don't know if you
guys know these two guys
and abilities yes yes well you know i
have a couple reasons why there might be
less sex going on during the pandemic
number one i think it's binging on tv
shows i think it's the content of tv
it's dark people watch the ozarks at
night they watch the undoing
they watch better call saul so much
content out there is so dark it doesn't
get you in the mood
for doing that i'm speaking for other
people and i'm looking for reasons plus
with people
on top of each other all day not
literally figuratively or whatever but
you know that plays a role in it too
they're seeing the same person and i
think
who could it be the wardrobe
i would see it is what is the greatest
stress reliever in the world
honestly like it's got to be the weird
it's got to be the other way around
it's got to be the other way it should
be logical it's got to be more it's got
to be like no
again my initial point i don't think
pandemics make people horny
what are you talking about oh okay i
know you're having a baby and uh you
know something about
uh covet is not about stopping doing
things in the bet david house dude let
me put it through this one yeah i tell
you i want to ask you a question
sure what and this goes to everybody
paul you can actually participate in
this as well
sam kai everybody if you want to
participate i'm excited what is
the number one give me your top three
stress reliever in your life what is it
i'm actually being serious with you
folks if you're listening to this please
participate what is your top three
stress relievers
some of the comment sections about to go
off yeah but what is your top three
your mind went to a place but i would
say yoga meditation
okay right all right uh that's your
number one yeah yeah when i think of
relieving stress i'm not like i gotta go
bang someone's like i'm not saying that
if
if you're in a relationship if you're in
a relationship and you got somebody if
you're in a relationship yeah
what are the top three stress relievers
i'm being serious with you can i answer
yeah i didn't know there were two others
i'm with him i didn't know that was a
stress reliever what are you
like what are you talking about like
okay are you like there's
play-on player one of the healthiest a
human being could do is have some
healthy sex
i'm not anti-sex man i'm good you know
what we find
to get him married we gotta finally
figure this out no
i'm all in on [ __ ] summer right now
adam's i'm none
i'm looking at the comment section i'm
actually asking you guys seriously i'm
going to give you seriously okay so
that's your first
give me your second and third there are
no others okay so fair fair okay
i'm with you there wait come on there
are no others give me yours there's a
lot of people
there's a lot of people that's not going
to get there's a lot of people that
smoke weed
watch a notebook what else smoking weed
what else is it a lot of people that
smoke weed there's a lot of people that
do yoga
with this stock lots of people but
nobody in this podcast but lots of
people smoke weed
lots of people you know yeah i mean sex
is the top three
okay here we go hey kai top three what's
your top three
uh i mean that hasn't been mentioned i'd
say taking a nap
nap
[ __ ] he's trying to say in the new
headquarters we're building we've got to
get a
bed set up how you doing baby to go
some people said jim we got daniel
aguero says jim
sleeping a lot of people said music
reading the bible
andrew junior yeah i do that i'd read
the bible and then i go nap and then i
go
let me go back i go pray for adam you
should actually read the
comment section it's hilarious
so what are they saying so here's the
point if you're under a lot of stress
i mean we got drink soy milk because
lower history
mike man he's like that mic i can take
it to a whole another level here
in 100 seriously this and it might segue
into our next
topic which is why i guarantee you and i
guarantee you this is
all 100 seriousness 99 of the problem in
bill and melinda gates
marriage was sex you think so i'll tell
you right that insider information
i don't need it i i have greatness i
don't need information i go with my gut
so you think i do you think it was bad
sex
i'm saying lack of sex bad sex not
turned on to each other hold on are you
trying to tell me
that bill can't hit it right with all
that data bill has you don't think he's
an analytics guy oh that guy is doing
some numbers crunching
six minutes and 28 seconds when i do
this
you got microsoft's a bad boy you take
the key yeah batman we
got mail yes you got some milk how about
the how about the naked swim
parties back in the day that was a
little creepy for microsoft
yeah let's go to that let's go real
quick uh here i have i do have a
production
i i predict this at the beginning of the
pandemic i think there's going to
definitely be
a baby boom a pandemic baby boom people
are like i would have to agree with that
people have been locked up i'm not
saying they're banging non-stop like
rabbits but some stuff went down you're
locked up you're in the house you can't
go out
the last 12 months yep has been probably
the most stressful 12 months a marriage
could have had
because of all these different things
that's going on you're dealing with kids
you're dealing with kids not going to
school in many states you're dealing
with work you're dealing with constant
new regulation
fear death you know the the stuff going
on with the
trump biden election protesting blm i
mean it was
stressful i totally that's why i think
if people real if you're married you're
in a relationship
hey one of the healthiest things you can
do is to
go you know practice the god-given
practices
actually go so you would think it would
be higher than it would be lower
go procreate go have us bring kids crazy
or with your partner i think yes i think
this uh people's relationships is much
like the famous new york song during
covid
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere if you can make it together
through a relationship
during coding yeah i mean you can make
it anywhere
wow sounds like that's profound stuff
that was that was sinatra
the next doctor phil right there dr
sauce
doctor philippe so bill gates since you
brought up bill gates bill gates
bill gates crafted a public image as a
likable nerdy do-gooder
gooder office affairs uncomfortable
workplace behavior and epstein ties
reveal cracks in his facade business
insider story
for decades bill gates has had this
persona but pleasant philanthropist
in contrast with the likes of tesla's
elon musk in twitter's jack dorsey gates
was likable relatable and
non-threatening but new reports about
the take founder in the wake of his
pending divorce from his wife of 27
years after a less flattering picture of
the man
reports from the new york times and wall
street journal indicates gates at times
treated the workplace like a pickup spot
making advances towards women who work
from the idea that gates viewed the
workplace as a
a trolling ground for dates may not come
as a surprise considering the origins of
his marriage gates met and began dating
melinda french in in 1987 after she took
a job
as a marketing manager at microsoft the
wall street journal on sunday reported
microsoft board hired a law firm to
investigate
yates in 2019 over claims he began an
affair within uh with a company
employing 2000 just six years after his
wedding
earlier this month the journal reported
that french gates has been considering
the divorce
uh divorce ever since uh since 2019
and she became upset over gate's
willingness to meet with the scrapes
uh disgraced financier jeffrey upstate
anyway there's a bunch of other stores
go ahead you tell us what's going on
over here you know what
regarding this divorce regarding bill
and melinda so for the life of their
marriage i always find them to be
i mean for lack of a better word very
creepy i just found the two of them
creepy or fake
both okay creepy fake robotic
cyborg-esque
just nothing real about them not even
human right insane wealth big
buying everything trying to tell
everybody what to do this is the first
time i found the two of them
actually human you know when they're
going through some actual human
pain emotion things that normal people
have to deal with
it's the first time the two of them have
ever seen normal now when they announced
that they were getting a divorce like
three mondays ago
the first thing that came to my mind is
what i just said bill wasn't getting
enough sex
and you might laugh about it but sex has
something to do with this marriage
falling apart
jeffrey epstein involved why are you
involved with jeffrey epstein
bill gates is 10 times smarter than
jeffrey epstein he's not doing it for
financial advice to invest
he's doing it for other reasons i don't
know what but for something else
and where does bill go next that's the
question because
look at some of these rich guys that
that get divorced they want to move on
they want to have fun
that there's that one thing in their
life that they haven't been able to
really experience is that loving
relationship
probably with a female and i look
that's part of their problem and i
mentioned earlier at the top of the show
you know one of the other bones of
contention between the two of them now
is the 10 million
inheritance that they were going to give
for the kids so melinda's brought in the
estate lawyers the
the inheritance lawyers and she's going
to amp it up a little bit but for the
first time ever i see these two people
as
as human beings and it's it's they hate
each other right now
every day there's a new story and it's
i'm sure bill would like to put the
little
do you think melinda's like behind
closed doors and what do you think
bill's like behind closed doors like how
do you see how do you see
each being like do you do you see
melinda being the
loving caring you know bill you're the
greatest ever do you think melinda is
more extremely competitive we're equal
i'm just as smart as you i'm just as
this
oh and then do you see bill being
passive aggressives like dude whatever i
don't even have time to argue this i do
realize who i am
how do you see them being behind closed
doors when they were married yeah i see
bill running off and doing other things
getting out of the house to avoid her i
see her being pretty tough on him
maybe for not being around the kids
enough maybe not doing things her way i
don't see her as the loving housewife
trying to make bill's life better i
think something that
comes to mind i know you're saying that
you know you didn't perceive bill and
melinda as human and almost robotic
i think something just to keep in mind
is no matter how many billions you have
how many zeros you have behind your name
everyone puts their pants on one leg at
a time like it's the same old thing and
it you know elon musk is worth 150
billion
like the only person that actually might
be a robot out there is maybe mark
zuckerberg he's the one person i'm a
little questionable about but
i think it's like you said this is
humanizing gates unfortunately it took
a um divorce for us to actually
realize that he's human uh but i think
bill's gonna be okay i think there's a
lot of
sapiosexuals out there to use a callback
daniel shout out to daniel yeah who's
one of the top sapiosexuals out there
and um i'm going
it was all that the late night dj talk
um but i think that i think there's a
lot of
women who are going to be very
attractive but he doesn't want a
sapiosexual that's what he's just no he
is
he you know he is the savior sex i think
there's going to be a lot of women out
there
they're going to be very attracted to
this newly single
billionaire smart guy eight-year-old
tatted guy with nose rings and
neck tattoos like dude i'm going
complete
she's going back to the boy yeah exactly
like the guy from uh
why him you know the movie why him yeah
james franco james franklin has been
getting the trouble
he's getting a little canceled yes he is
from his own best friend from his own
uh seth rogen saying i'll never work
with him yeah so somebody like him can
you imagine melinda get shows up with
somebody like him
why him melinda why him why not a tattoo
of a christmas card
you've got this one life and you just
got to go with your gut
you know and that's what makes you feel
good go for it everyone's like
one thing that i think we can all agree
with no matter
what you do you're going to be judged no
matter what you do if you say this
and you think you're right people are
going to judge you if you if you're
going here to the left or what people
are going to judge you so at the end of
the day
i think you just kind of got to do what
what feels right and uh
not worry about the canceled culture the
wokeness or the people thinking you're
to this here to that
and uh go with what feels right yeah i
think i think bill
probably enjoys life maybe more than we
think he does
you know i think some of this is
creeping out a little bit with uh you
know the pool parties back in the day
i'm sure that wasn't just a one-time
thing
i know he's involved in some very very
exclusive private clubs around the
country so it's
and he's a golfer you know he probably
enjoys life so what's the pool party
tell us about the pool party
okay so this came out um that back in
the day before he was married
that they were having um they would hire
they would go to sex
clubs in seattle and hire some of the
workers there to come
to the house to do naked swim parties
with bill and some of his friends that's
how
they would blow off steam back in the
coding days in the garage
you know all that all day they need it
it's good to know that he's normal it's
good to know that he's normal
do you like him more now are you going
to switch from apple products to
microsoft products so you're going to
start like doubling down on their
software and
you know i'll say this about bill he's a
fighter you know he's an intense fighter
a very competitive guy
how competitive does he bring that to
the divorce does he try to crush her
or is he i mean he's got to be very very
careful here right because if you listen
to stories
about how he was building that company
he was tough you know he was very
aggressive very he had no problem
squashing people
destroying people and this you know you
get your gloves up when you're in a
divorce man i mean it's just
it makes you it takes you to a different
place that you don't want to be
and i think i think the media is
probably making it even more intense the
all these stories coming out and them
going through it you know it's probably
pissing them off even more but how long
do you think this is going to last how
long do you think this is going to last
can this you think they're going to drag
this out for a long time i think they
had a head start on it the way it
sounded like they were having some of
this stuff discussed a couple
years before the announcement was made
yeah so i think they got a lot of it in
place but i think melinda's probably
sitting back and seeing that public
sentiment
is leaning towards her and her lawyers
are gonna smell blood
and they're gonna go for more and if
they see that he's vulnerable i i would
imagine this could get very very
contentious
that would be my prediction i don't know
if it's gonna get as contentious as
you're predicting i think this is
something they've been working out for a
while
uh they had no uh
prenup prenup uh sorry about that never
been married with a prenup so
i forgot about that they don't have a
prenup in place and i think this is
something they're gonna work out behind
closed doors i think it's
the media and i think it's just public
perception oh bill gates
he's banging this and he's doing this
and he's having sex with pool parties
and he's just like like man i'm just
gonna buy some more farmland
i think they're gonna be very very uh i
think they're gonna it's gonna be ugly i
really think scale of one to ten how
ugly
ten being the ugly okay ten being war of
the roses remember that movie with danny
devito
i would give it an eight point an eight
point eight eight point eight
what about you how bad it's gonna be
yeah i think the ugliness is already
done
so what's your number oh i i think it
was ugly a year ago and it was a nine
and a half
and i think from here on it's just
negotiation i think it's a seven moving
forward
okay yeah i think they're just going to
wrap it up and be done and move on
i think both of them are probably
looking forward to it i agree i actually
think it's going to be a three yeah
i don't think it's going to be that
correct both
and just go about them and you know who
probably look is looking forward to
the most the kids the kids are probably
like dude
parents figure this thing out and let's
go already are there
yeah they've got kids that are adults oh
yeah yeah they got they gotta kiss one
i know that they're adults i i assume
they're in their twenties what do you
think the youngest was three
no i thought i figured 25 to 35. he's 70
years old almost you know what
i think kids take sides into divorce or
i think the possibility is there if
one state if maybe especially if they're
younger but they can be easily
influenced now here's
the media is all over this story right
now and i think the potential is there
to dig up more stories on bill gates
which could piss melinda on jennifer
can't capps see melinda go into our
lawyers and say give me five more
billion
this is [ __ ] i just read this story
what he did eight years ago and he never
told me but let me ask you a question
here's a crazy question for you some
pictures do you think anything's gonna
come out on her
no i i don't know i don't i might my
first thought is no i don't think so why
is that
a because the media has already dug in
that bill gates is the target
and b she was raising kids i don't think
that was probably her nature
to maybe you know wander off i'm not
talking about wandering off that's not
the direction i'm going but other kind
of stories that
could come out about her like what i
don't know i mean some
hard to live with i'm talking about how
you know
like like ellen degeneres stories yeah
that's what i'm saying like i'm saying
like a story like that hey i'm
finally retiring and i'm going to go a
different side you're not really
retiring the audience kind of fired you
that's kind of what happened you went
from being the lovable
everyone loves ellen to they don't
really love you like they used to
we got to go find the next person to
have a show for 10 20 year run rate
until they fire the next person because
go get me the next ellen
go give me the next alan trap for 10
years before the audience fires her
or him it's just kind of how things work
that's right it is the shelf life
on top so anyways let's go to the next
story here um
california home let's go to paid seven
california home uh uh
if you wanna buy a this is actually a
good story for california we gotta give
a little bit of a
positive story for california so found
your california dream home
good luck with that it may be gone by
tomorrow this is an l.a times story
the four bedroom house in north tustin
went on the market on thursday that
saturday vic and sarah
were inside checking out the mid-century
living room and debating how they could
remodel the kitchen in the 1.1 million
dollar listing
if they wanted to act they didn't have
much time offer were due
tuesday homes are selling at warp speed
nationwide forcing would-be buyers to
make snap decisions on what is typically
the biggest purchase of their lives
in california houses haven't sold faster
than at least three decades according to
data
from state's main realtors association
in march a homes median time
on the market in the golden state was
eight days that's insane
eight days the shortest time period
recorded by california social
realtors whose database goes back in
1990 in the bubble years 2003 to 2005
homes typically took more than 20 days
to sell in the hot market years
preceding the pandemic the median inc a
medium time on a market
at times dipped further hitting a low of
14 days in 2017.
eight days you put the house in the
market within eight days of selling
that's insane
to be thinking about that and it's all
over the country you really don't hear
about any market where there isn't
bidding wars on every house
and then there's also these other
factors that have come into it if you're
a home buyer if you're building a new
home
is the cost of wood right now they say
that the cost of wood is so high
lumber because of the supply chain
issues that they've had over the past
year that you if you're building a house
add on another 36 000
on average per house because of the wood
shonda my wife is an interior decorator
and if you want to order new appliances
right now she said
six months six months wait so by the way
right now at ten o'clock i got
a uh uh interior decorator that's
looking at uh uh one of the houses that
we're looking at to to help get the
place to uh fixed up and he says
here's our limit our limit's a minimum
of two hundred thousand dollars and this
is what we take
and honestly uh i if you say no to we
don't have a lot of time so this is kind
of what we're working with right now
that's like wait a minute what are you
talking about
like 10 people you call they're all
saying the same thing yeah we're so
booked we can't when you need it is it
like a month from now two months from
now i know we need it like that
we can't do that so it is a very
different
market today on who benefits from this
but the question becomes
how long this is going to last the
challenge sometimes happens had a friend
of mine who was an interior interior
designer and he would also come in and
actually do the work
his best year in 2006 he made 1.6
million dollars
for him that's a lot of money he made
1.6 million dollars in 2006.
do you know what happened to that 201.6
million dollar income three years later
the third crash
six to six hundred thousand dollars to a
hundred and fifty
grand nine percent ninety percent ninety
percent drop off so here's the
if you're listening to this and you're
one of the guys that's making a lot of
money more money than you've ever made
in your entire life
take whatever your income is this year
and divide it by five years
look at that as your real income if you
make two million this year
look at it as you only made 400 thousand
dollars this year over the next
five years if you're making a million
this year you didn't make a million this
year you really made 200 000
this year if you can look at your income
that way
you'll have it when the bad times come
because it's not going to be like this
for too long look no
there's two indicators when we talk
about inflation today we'll launch a
video
on inflation kai what's the title of the
video on inflation uh
the dangers of inflation and the futures
of america like how it affects right so
there's two things that affect the
market that controls the market who are
the two puppet masters of the market
fed fed and the other one is the
government right you got the fed in the
government
those are the two puppet masters feds
increase rates when the market is doing
very good
and the feds lower rates when the market
is doing what
that and they're scared about it now the
last 12 years the last 10 years
what have the rates been less than one
percent it's been less than one percent
since obama
to trump to now biden right janet yellen
indirectly says the rates are going to
go up and the reason why janet yellen
says is because she was what before
she was the chairman of the fed chairman
of the fed so she says the rates are
going to go
wait a minute who are you you can't say
something like that that's not your job
that's powell's job
so she got in trouble she had to come
back and apologize the next day
if she's hinting that the rates going up
whoever's buying anything today for
cheap money
it's going to change in the next 12 to
24 months it is not going to stay like
this forever people have to realize this
so
this craziness that's going on my
biggest concern is
a lot of people are buying ferraris
lambos
s 600s whatever they're buying with
money that they're not going to have two
years from now
what is the famous line that you say
save that what
save them save that money if there's
ever been a time to be very
careful with your cash savings because
they're gonna do this tax rates this is
not going away
they're gonna raise the taxes it's
probably not going to be 39.6 on capital
gains
it's probably not going to be 28 for
corporate it's probably going to be 25
for corporate and it's probably going to
be you know 33 percent for capital gains
is still up what 13 on 20. that's a lot
of money we're talking about
so if you can get some cash right now
and sit on it
do so because in the next two three four
years
there's going to be some stuff that's
going to be taken by the when i'm saying
cash i'm not saying cash like you just
sit on cash because cash
inflation is going to hurt you i'm
saying put it in a place that you'll
have access to in the next two years
because
if you go in the spending spree right
now
it's almost like this you ever seen a
fighter that comes in
like it's these videos that do so well
get 50 million views the guy comes out
ufc and his poking fingers in the guy's
face
and the other guy's just staying quiet
right and there was one boxer back in
the days he would do the footwork and
would make fun of you and slap together
whatever his name was right prince ali
prince he would do all this stuff and
then one of the videos he's doing this
and he's like looking so good
next thing you know he's a little too
cocky he gets caught
drops i mean it's terrible that video on
facebook's got 40 50 million views
everybody wants to everybody wants to
see cocky people
have a big fall it's something people
like they like to see trolls
yes people love that right so all i'm
saying is
if somebody's making money right now
more power to you man i'm excited for
you
don't over live your current lifestyle
thinking this money is going to come
forever it is not going to come forever
like this
some people are making lucky money you
know who you are if you're making lucky
money
whatever income you make the best way to
gauge your income i know you know the
podcast we go into a lot of different
topics this is the best way to gauge
your income
take your income if you made a million
and a half this year
you made seven hundred thousand dollars
last year and you made three hundred
thousand dollars the year before
you know in my eyes what you're no
matter what income is three hundred
three hundred thousand dollars
if you made one and a half million this
year you made 1.6 million last year
you made 1.5 million the year before
guess what your income is you're a one
and a half million dollar guy more power
to you
so there's a big difference between this
guy living at the one and a half million
dollar lifestyle then the person that
made one and a half million this year
two years ago they were making 300 000
the people that went from 300 to 1.5
with lucky money
they're going to get destroyed in the
next two years it's going to be very
very ugly in two years it's going to go
back to 2008 years when
you know you were buying 200 000 lambos
for 85 000 a guy comes to me
brings a yellow lamb but says dude just
take this from me so what do you mean he
says i bought the sack too just give me
eighty five thousand i said eighty five
thousand says
why'd you pay for 250. he just bought it
for 250 year and a half ago
she wants eighty five thousand dollars
so there's gonna be a lot of those
opportunities next two years well that
means there's gonna be good deals on
houses in a couple plenty so
plenty in the next two years you
extrapolate that exactly let's say
you're making 50 grand then you go to
120 grand and then you make 180 same
thing i do with the same thing
if i don't make the same money three
years i don't buy stuff
on the number that i make three years
gotcha i don't buy stuff on
numbers i don't make three years you
just have to look at your numbers that
way yeah you can't get caught up in that
i made uh
300 grand this year but i usually make
80 grand look you're new
yeah i've been in this business for 20
years you know how many guys i've had
make
100 000 in a month 50 000 in a month and
i tell them listen you didn't make
fifty thousand dollars this month you
didn't make a hundred thousand dollars
this month
you really if you take your six month
average you made a hundred thousand
dollars plus the prior
uh five months is 40 grand you made 140
divided by five is what
you made barely 28 000 act like you make
twenty eight not you made a hundred
thousand dollars
but unfortunately guess what happens
when a person makes a hundred they get
the rolex
they get the ferragamo they get the tom
ford they get their stuff on the right
they get all this nice stuff that comes
to them
and next thing you know hey i don't have
any money two years later they got tax
issues
i couldn't agree more i couldn't agree
more so because especially if you're in
an industry
where you can make some big commissions
like there's been some times where i've
made a huge pop
100 grand a month ridiculous i just put
that [ __ ] right you know when i bought
my first rolex
asked me when i bought my first roll pat
when did you buy your first roll
five years ago at 37 years old five
years ago do you know when i could
afford to buy rolex at 20 12 years ago
at 25 years old yeah but i bought a
rolex five years why'd you wait so long
when did i buy my first ferragamo what
do you think first ferragamo shoes 550
shoes four years ago 29 years old my
first
jay's 30 years old i've never had a
jordan until 30 years old
tell us why the point it's you you
cannot
there cannot be this facade that you
have real money
yeah there are people that have real
money there are people that are
making good money it's a big difference
if you're making the money and you're
living a lifestyle that you cannot
afford it's not sustainable
half the time it's let me see what this
guy's doing let me see what that guy's
doing for me
uh uh i'm about freedom i'm about peace
of mind i'm about
calm i'm about having a lot of those
things sometimes there is risk don't get
me wrong behind closed doors i got a lot
of my money that's also on risk because
i'm going for the big pop like you know
how we talked about earlier
when you said uh you know there's going
to be a lot of idiots that lose a lot of
their money in the next couple years
with whoever dogecoin or bitcoin or
whatever
and i said there's going to be a lot of
idiot millionaires there just is
but you know what is what is a real
idiot
somebody could have taken a risk and
he's worth 78 million dollars but
he was one day away from being a broke
idiot
but people say what what a freaking
genius that guy's just so you know a
very wealthy person
is one decision away from being an idiot
of course this is what people forget you
see somebody that won at the highest
level you think oh
this guy must be a he's not he just made
a couple very good decisions and he was
a little bit more patient than his peers
yeah just like everything else in life
luck plays a huge role in everybody's
success and timing
you know being in the right place at the
right time next story by the way
64 of millennials have regrets about
buying their current home
this is a cnbc story okay nearly
two-thirds or 64
millennials ages 25 to 40 years old say
they have they have at least one regret
about purchasing their current home
according to a new poll
of more than 1400 u.s homeowners and
from bank rate
only 45 of gen x 41 to 56 and 33
of boomers 57 and 75 have reported some
type of remorse about the current home
they found but overall having some
dissatisfaction is pretty common about
of all homeowners have at least one
regret about their home among all
homeowners including millennials the
most common regret is underestimating
how much the maintenance expenses and
other hidden costs associated
with buying and owning a home other
types of regress focus on the size of
the home and the finances involved in
the process including the mortgage
payment and rate
adam i'm gonna turn this to you yeah
i've said it before and i'll say it
again home ownership
ain't all that it's cracked up to be and
there's big three things you need
there's the big three things that you
need to keep in mind and they said it in
this article
oh i didn't realize that maintenance was
going to be this much there's three
things you have to keep in mind if
you're gonna be a homeowner that you do
not have to pay
if you're renting maintenance is one of
them taxes
is the other big one and then insurance
all right homeowners insurance
so people don't get into that they think
oh i'm gonna get this house i can make
the payment it's all good the interest
rate is pretty reasonable
sounds good i'm gonna just buy the house
it seems great and they forget about
these big three factors the big three
expenses that you're gonna have to come
out of pocket for
and you touched on this earlier be wary
of where you're getting your your
advice you touch on this earlier and
when you hear a realtor or someone who's
a developer say
why would you put your why would you
rent you're throwing all your money away
you're throwing all your money away
renting who's giving that advice
like you said someone that wants to sell
a house exactly and and you said well
you know be patient stay in the market
stay in the market why would you leave
the market who's saying that
somebody that ultimately probably works
on wall street so
yeah julie swenson right now just gave
five bucks and she said i don't agree
with the home prices due to birth rates
we are easily going to see appreciation
the next five years right
so julie here's my response to you i
don't disagree
that real estate is a bad investment
today here's why hear me out let me tell
you how i'm
processing this when inflation takes
place
who wins whatever that can't be
duplicated let me say one more time
when inflation takes place who wins
whatever that can't be copied and
duplicated
what does that mean you cannot copy more
land
you cannot duplicate more land like
prime land is going to be valuable
for a very very long if you got premier
premier land
located in a place where families are
going to want to go and birth rates is
going up they're going to want like
let's just say take the best private
schools
okay take the best private school in
omaha nebraska
take the best private schools in
whatever in la in chicago in dallas in
florida in miami take the best private
schools
and then go to the best community in
that close to the private school maybe
it's a gated community maybe it's a good
area
that community forever is going to do
well as long as that private school
does well because families with money
who can afford to pay
15 20 30 40 000 for private school are
willing to go live near
that school so i do agree with her the
only challenge i have
isn't the fact that long-term real
estate is not going to go up the
challenge i have is
people who are buying stuff that they
cannot afford
people who are living a lifestyle today
that's not really their lifestyle
overextending that is that is not a
smart move to be making
and a lot of people are making a move
right and it might be some of these
millennials that now have the regrets
right about buying the house
you know that that's a shocker for a
young person um there's no landlord to
call when the plumbing goes down or the
roof leaks or something like that and
that's expensive
have you had to have a plumber come over
that's hundreds and hundreds of dollars
it's unbelievable the other thing that
this story about the millennials you
know points to me
is have a little gratitude i mean
they're always looking for the negative
thing about regrets and this and that
how about you know no one put a gun to
your head to make you buy these houses
and i think it also speaks to the fact
like a little bit what you mentioned
adam they weren't looking for advice
from people that maybe were
owners of homes and what they should
look out for maybe a little arrogance
creeps into it like they have all the
answers and i'm just gonna buy a home
now
because i can afford a down payment but
there are some some hidden
little misery items there that you got
to prepare yourself for and one other
thing is
um you know they talk about the american
dream you talked about financial freedom
a little bit ago you used that
terminology the the american dream
back in the day where it's ironic that
baby boomers a third of them
have regrets whereas two-thirds of
millennials have regrets and ultimately
i think that's because the american
dream
has changed american dream back in the
day when you know our parents were
really coming to age in the 80s and we
were all
basically being born um was to
have a house in the suburbs let's say
work in the same job for the next 40
years get your gold watch get your
pension
retire kind of have stability the
american dream has changed
significantly these days that it's all
about work from anywhere financial
freedom
uh travel live your best life and not
necessarily being tied down
i think that i'm a huge proponent of is
having high flexibility
and low overhead so look at my life in
the last 12 months i lived in miami
i lived in dallas i lived in boca and we
might be moving again in the next
we are going to be okay so the point is
if i was locked in well pat i'd love to
be a part of valuetainment but i've got
a house in pembroke
true but i want you to think about it
you want to be married one day no
correct you want to have kids one day
yes do you think the uber lifestyle is
going to work if you're married
no do you think no i'm actually not
being funny i'm actually being very
serious but i will tell you one
where it does work so yes i agree at
some point if you have kids you're going
to need a house you're going to be your
car absolutely that you you work out
i'm looking at you the guy was you were
vascular coming back after basketball
basketball
you're going to want to teach your kids
how to play basketball you're one of the
best athletes that came out of high
school here playing football you had all
these records with basketball you were
an athletic guy so yeah
so if you want to drop these guys so so
what i'm saying to you is i think
the approach you took to save your money
it is genius on what you did and i think
more people ought to take a play out of
your playbook
but that is with the intentions of
saving money because once you are
married yes
you get to choose what zip code you want
to raise your kids in you get to choose
what private school you want to put your
kids in
if you want to raise your kids with the
religious beliefs that your family has
maybe you want to
raise them with a private school that a
link to a jewish community if you want
to do that great if you want to put them
in pine crest if you want to put you
could do that you have those options
but it's it's with the plans of
eventually having
choices forever it's not sustainable to
be like that single maybe in new york
yeah
i don't think it's going to be
sustainable i totally agree with you i
totally agree with you i sacrificed in
my all throughout my 30s
to save money not to have major expenses
like sacrifice listen you all you it's
not like you
listen you've had more fun than a
hundred single men combined so it's not
like you haven't had the phone let's not
say sacrifice like
it was a sacrificial lamb outside of the
bar you're like got a little freaking
you know oh my gosh drinks when i say
sacrifice
meaning i still haven't bought a rolex
for 20 g's
i still haven't bought a lambo for 200
grand could i have yes but i'd rather
save that money invest that money
so when i'm in my 40s i'm not freaking
out stressing over
you also don't even care you have a
certain fashion that you follow
black white blue jeans and shoes and
it's very basic that's kind of hard
i think i think this is something that i
already cut your own hair or somebody
else
i got my i go to this guy rapper tony
but i think
there there is a by the way he looked
great in dallas that hair is ridiculous
i don't know how old rapperton is in his
fifties he's the guy that's
ridiculous he's making he's doing very
well something that i will say
is that you get so caught up
in materialism and consumerism on the
latest
gucci belt and then and and then driving
this car and the fashion
there's something just so awesome and
just being comfortable
dude i got a black t-shirt on i got no
jewelry good for you but i feel great
i'm not even saying for me
yeah for our audience sure it's not
about the stuff that materialism
some people about being comfortable i
don't i i think for me it's
whatever drives you okay i think it's
what you broke it down in your
four different whatever drives you and
that drives you i love it whatever
drives him i love it whatever drives
sean
i love it whatever drives me i love it
it's whatever drives the individual
but i think there's more leaning towards
having some of the money in the bank
today because
just assume bad times are usually coming
every five to ten years it's just
every ten years we have a recession that
flat out it's just the numbers run that
way
about every ten years five to ten years
yeah sometimes two to four years but
it's five to ten years we have a
recession
and those who are prepared for it guess
what they end up being called the
geniuses
and you can act as much as you want that
you're making real money today
it's not as by the way let me let me
make a prediction to you let me make a
prediction to you
let's just say let's just say let's just
say
let's just say in the next 24 months
dow goes to 25 bitcoin goes to 8 800.
unemployment goes to 8.8 it's kind of
throwing numbers out there okay
unemployment goes to 8.8
taxes go to the roof biden actually does
what he does
okay taxes go to the roof uh money
supply is not looking pretty
china is blowing up growing you know
doing incredible things
okay all of these things that are taking
place
those people that were sitting on
millions of dollars you think they're
shopping the way they are
no no the 300 that they're saying
they're about to cut in how many
different states what was the number
with 300
how many states are being cut nearly 2
million americans will lose that 300
unemployment benefit this summer that's
a lot of people
two million people so that's about to go
away yeah but there's eight million jobs
that are open it just goes to show they
don't want to work
you're right you're right what did
applebee's just announced kai what was
it applebee's that announced they're
hiring ten thousand
people and they're having a hard time
finding it by the way applebee's is
paying bonuses just to apply
yes what's going on they're begging
people to get a job
and they're not wanting but we're going
two different directions here where were
you going with all the stats
where i'm going with this when that
happens if that happens
okay who then is the genius two years
from now
the people sitting on the cash now with
their money such as who the people that
listen to me and save that money such as
who else
give me big names such as who as far as
buffalo warren buffett yeah people are
going to say this flipping conservative
money you know what value
investors this guy yeah by the way it's
not if when this happens which you
i'm just saying that's actually the
scenario that you just played out i
think is very reasonable in the next
fight so and then people gonna say wow
you know warren buffett you know he
maybe he really maybe monger maybe this
maybe that
so look i'm i'm of the place that we
the moment you no longer listen to the
youngins you have a blind spot
the the moment you also don't take
counsel from the old
experience just kind of you also have
blind spots by the way i think it's both
though
i think too often we're coming from a
place of well
you know i know what i'm talking about
and all this stuff do you realize
you know i have shoes older than you
those [ __ ] type of lines people say
listen that's showing you got a blind
spot
yeah i got shoes older than you no it's
when i wanted to find out about social
media works i sat next to a girl who was
candy's daughter her name is phoebe she
was 14 years old
she's now uh doing great in her life
shout out to the candy family
kenny nelly i'm sitting next to ellen
hawaii uh not ellie
phoebe next message phoebe tell me about
what social media app you're using right
now
and she said seriously yes yeah i said
what grade are you in i'm in 10th grade
ninth grade what social media app you're
using right now
she says everyone's using snapchat i
said snapchat yeah i said not facebook
this is like 10 years ago
she says no everyone's using stats so
can you show me snapchat how does this
work she shows me snapchat then i'm in
bakersfield the girl named shawna bledo
and
marlene corminares they say pat why are
you not on snapchat so what do you mean
snapchat this is eight nine years ago
they show me snapchat i listen to them
and i'm like oh this guy's got these
millions of subscribers whatever i'm
listening to the youngins on what's
going on
but if these guys get too cocky with
that they lose if the youngins
don't take the council and say dude
listen i've seen 10 markets
right i've seen 10 ups and downs i'm
telling you may be up to something with
crypto
but i'm just telling you you may want to
take a little bit of experience on what
i've seen happen
over the last i think what you're saying
is it works both ways yes
cyclical they both have blind spots when
the olden experience get too cocky
they get destroyed and replaced when the
young and energetic
get too cocky they lose tens of years of
their lives because they could have
saved that 10 years
by listening to somebody who made that
mistake 40 years before they were even
born so i think there's an element of
learning from both but i want to go to
las vegas big news las vegas just came
out
talking about the fact that opening up
nine vegas casinos get green lit
uh to open at 100 capacity this is an
associate press story
uh a gambling giant mgm resorts
international wednesday joined a growing
number
of las vegas strip casinos page six with
state regulatory approval to open
casinos floor at 100 capacity
and no person-to-person distancing
requirement the company said the nevada
gaming control board
granted its waiver for nine properties
based on his workforce vaccination
approval applies to casino floors at
bellagio aria mgm grand mandalay bay
mirage new york new york
luxor excalibur and park mgm three foot
distance sync and 80 percent occupancy
restrictions remain at restaurants
swimming pools and other non-gambling
areas masks are still required
clark county lawmakers with jurisdiction
over las vegas area businesses have
approved
plans to 100 occupancy over 60 eligible
county residents get a
vaccine a vaccine shot as of tuesday the
figure was at 47
the other las vegas casino is open 100
including win las vegas encore
cosmopolitan resorts known as the strat
they showed gambling uh control board at
80 percent employees have received at
least one shot of chronovirus vaccine
good to hear vegas being back it's great
finally vegas is sitting around saying
holy freaking molly how much more
money are we going to lose to texas and
to florida they see canelo's fight
cowboy stadium they see nba
all-star game uh they see nba playoffs
florida they see a super bowl florida
they see all this stuff taking place
like listen
how much money you think cost vegas by
seeing what florida and texas did
what is the number hundreds of billions
billions of dollars the number one
convention city in the world potentially
the number one convention city in the
world is back open i'm excited about
this
thank god it's about time and you know
it finally feels like common sense is
kind of returning in this country
and you know good for vegas i guarantee
you they were chomping at the bit to
open way way sooner but they were their
hands were tied and they couldn't
um you know you got the raiders with the
highest price tickets in the nfl they're
going to be
huge this year imagine they just opened
up that new stadium in vegas they
couldn't even play in it last year
it's going to be insane what football
weekends are going to be like in vegas
you got the hockey team that just
started the playoffs again
and you know what these casinos should
be wide open they should be you know
what if you
are overweight if you have some
cardiovascular issues if you have
uh circulatory issues if you have some
sort of health don't go
because maybe you're you know it's date
just like everything else in this world
during the pandemic
the last 14 months but we were so caught
up in protecting everybody and not
having any common sense by saying
hey you know what if you have these
issues your life is in danger
this is a serious threat for you old
people etc
take caution quarantine don't but
everybody else should have been out
you know in the whole thing but that's a
whole nother story but thank god if
vegas is open
that sets the that sets kind of like the
the bar for everybody else and it's okay
to open up everywhere
so speaking from a consumer mindset
because i want to flip this over to you
and get your perspective but speaking
from a consumer mindset i mean i'd go to
vegas once a year maybe for a country
i'm not a vegas guy no i mean i live in
south beach why the hell do i need to go
to vegas
okay like yeah so you're not somebody
that went to bake you i would go i would
go for
this officer there's so much that south
beach doesn't i mean i think i mean hey
you can gamble number one
b you can go you're good you can gamble
you can you can get
you can gamble in south florida you can
go to the hard drive and i don't think
of miami as the finest dining i know
there's good restaurants i know there is
but you go to vegas for the dining as
well
the spa i think you'd you don't again
i'd go to vegas once a year i'd go
on a business trip i'd go on a bachelor
party i'd go for a little vacay whatever
once a year like that that that so cool
from a consumer standpoint
all right i missed my vegas trip this
year no big deal but
you throw a freaking massive
convention in vegas from a business
owner's standpoint who puts on
yeah mega conferences this has to be
because you want to have fun wait this
is
this has to be ridiculous oh yeah i mean
we have nikki jam performing we have
[ __ ]
mike tyson will be there we have
frederick de silva the top illusionist
and pretty much all of america
yeah we have mario lopez mario lopez
mario lopez similar mario but mario
roberts just as good looking just
patrick glencione a bunch of other guys
that we're also still working on but the
point is
when i went to mgm last uh two weeks ago
i don't know what it was two or three
weeks like you physically went to vegas
oh yeah i was at mgm grand and i was
talking to all the employees okay and
they're giving us the tour and all this
stuff because we're kind of setting up
on hey how are you going to fit 12 13
000 people here
how are we going to talk about in the
arena where the ufc fights
we're renting we're shutting down all of
them jim grant that's what we're doing
to do an event in two and a half months
you ought to come flying
yeah for sure it's a sick show the award
ceremony you're gonna say it's one of
the greatest shows you've ever seen
and if it's anything like the event
ceremony that just went on in dallas
that's
that's that's nothing that's what's
crazy about it i'm excited to say this
anyways so i went there and i and i go
through my guys and i talk to my guys
and uh my guys people that i've been
doing stuff with you know av once you
work with an av team you kind of like
buddies together i saw my guy lee
yeah you know adam sanders guy whether
it's marshall all these guys we've been
doing so many things together right nice
guys
so anyways i'm in the back in mgm i'm
like so tell me what's going on with
work here pat you don't even know what's
going on tell me what's going on
dude 90 of people don't have a job what
do you mean ninety percent of you
ninety percent of my guys don't have a
job how are they making it today they're
struggling
unemployed they're struggling and all
this stuff is not cutting it it's not
enough
this is very scarce so when do you think
it's gonna open i hope soon
people need jobs we need people coming
in you
you you could tell how excited they were
that we have still kept our contract
that we're doing our event with them
it was a risk because we signed a
contract and we did the deal with kovitz
so we announced we're doing an event pre
vegas being open
open it was a risk it was a big risk we
took a lot of our competitors and it's
an irresponsible thing to do
maybe you're right but dana white listen
he opened up ufc
and he says we're opening up let
everybody else follow suit we didn't
slow down with that
we're putting the commission the biggest
part about this that i'm excited is the
fact that those
workers who love putting events together
who get a kick out of putting a great
show supporting all of that
they finally are back they have jobs
they can now sell tickets
sell con concert sell rooms sell out the
place do all that other stuff that
people do
i'm very this is very very big for
america
to see vegas being open very big for
america think about it
how much love did you get when you took
500 people down to hawaii
oh hawaii treated us royally because
they hadn't had any tourism in a year
they're so royal they mean
you show up with 500 people and it's
like holy thank you for coming by the
way
you told that story so we had a trip
going to bora bora right we have a trip
going to bora bora
that we had to cancel uh two weeks ago
and here's why bora bora
we we have the bungalow set up
everything it's the most
exclusive island that we had in bora
bora we were shutting down all the
bungalows we took all of them right
and it's not 500 bucks a night it's
expensive when you get these bungalows
when you're shutting down an island
they call us and they say you can come
but bora bora state laws is the
following
everyone has to be vaccinated or
they have to quarantine for two weeks
yeah so we had a conference because we
asked
our guys our guys like dude we're not
doing this so what what am i going to do
so now we're looking at other places a
bunch of places are closed maldives is
open
jamaica's open aruba is open bahamas is
a lot of different places are open but
it's it's so
interesting now that the criteria to
take a incentive trip company trip
you have to look at state laws on who
doesn't require you to do
this whole thing with vaccine yesterday
i asked the question on twitter saying
how many of you guys this is what i ask
i said how many of you guys on twitter
are let me pull this up to see the
survey
and it's it's the most common question
right now being asked i said did you get
the vaccine shot
i put yes as a poll no thinking about it
not going to period right so yes
28 i got the vaccine shot 4 000 people
pulled on this
no 35 haven't gotten it yet thinking
about it
11 not going to period 26
not going to period so you're seeing a
lot of messaging right now with what's
going on with hey you better get this
you better get the shot so even
traveling
vegas it's going to get a little tricky
delta's talking about they want to see
potentially a vaccine car to fly i think
there's going to be an uproar if they
take that kind of a position
but uh you know i talked to subramanian
swami from india
who sits on the cabinet is a one of the
most influential people in all of india
professor at harvard he is good friends
with modi since the 70s the guy is a
beast of a guy he's gotten millions on
top of millions of views on youtube
probably in his late 70s early 80s and
we talk about what's going on with india
last seven day average on covet cases
400 000 a day
death seven day average four thousand a
day so i said why do you think this
happened he says you know what's crazy
we are the biggest producers of the
covet vaccine in our country we have two
different kind of accidents one of them
killed nearly 200 people i believe
that's the number he gave and the other
one is doing better
he says but we got too sloppy we got a
little too comfortable
and because we got a little too
comfortable that's what took place here
with us in india and now we're
struggling to kind of slow this thing
down because it's not slowing down so
there is that fear of what if something
happens like that in the states but the
reality of it is florida and texas
has proven that there is ways to come
back and still control it again
what did he mean sloppy and uh getting
too comfortable they he got a little too
cocky he's saying modi got too cocky and
he got up and he said in february
we are down to 11 000 cases a day in a
country with 1.4 billion people living
there
hey let us teach the rest of the world
how to do it and then next thing you
know
boom that took off by the way where are
you going so not bora bora would you
pick
we we had a conference call last night
at midnight 12 30 and we're right now
looking at a couple different places i'm
about to announce it on a conference
call right after
yeah so i'll announce it next week i'll
i just don't want to reveal it because
by the way there's nothing more
depressing for america than seeing the
strip in vegas dead
and nobody there yeah i mean that sets
the tone and that's just like just
saying man we're screwed
so the fact that it's going to be crazy
i mean people are going to make up for
lost time yeah real quick i'm excited
about look if
you if you're enjoying today's podcast
smash thumbs up and subscribe to the
podcast
if you think you've already subscribed
this is a completely different channel
we only got 60 000 something subscribers
we'd love to take this to a million subs
if you want to see this thing grow give
us a sub give us a thumbs up it helps us
with the algorithms let's talk about
teachers union
teacher page 10 teachers union leader
calls for fully reopening schools this
fall this is a political
story af aft president randy
weingarten called for schools to reopen
full time and in person and
this fall and set out multi-million
dollar outreach campaign to coax a coax
uh pronounce that word for me families
back to campuses as president joe biden
administration passes for quick
resumption of uh regular classes the
chief of the 1.7 million member
labor group said political pressure from
republican lawmakers didn't factor into
her school
reopening call to the aft on thursday
really let me read that one more time
the chief of the 1.7 million member
labor group said political pressure from
republican lawmakers didn't factor into
her school
reopening call to the aft on thursday
nor she said
did any new coronavirus would biden
administration
about school reopening during the cover
19 pandemic she instead cited expanded
eligibility for cronovirus vaccines her
own business to schools carrying out the
federal
safety guidance for reopening plus
hundreds of billions of dollars in
federal aid now being delivered to k-12
schools anyways we're going to see
what's going to happen the good news is
that there are finally
people from teachers union realizing
keeping kids at home
not only hurts marriages nonstop you're
hurting people to get back to work
because some parents can't afford to
have a
babysitter to be with the kid when
they're going to school there's a lot of
different risks there finally
i talked to a friend of mine yesterday
she called we had a conversation
together
and she lives in la she's got three kids
her and her husband my husband's one of
my
top five best friends i have good guy
you met him before so
we're having a conversation together and
i said she said so how are things it's
the kids i've been going back to school
the entire time what are you talking
about yeah there was like slight little
break in texas
but they've been going back to school
you're serious yeah i said how are
things over there in california pat do
you understand
no one's going to school they're home
period period
like what are you talking about too it's
as if you're living in a different world
they're finally getting so
here's what's starting to happen with
politics let me tell you what's starting
to happen with politics
democrats and republicans okay sometimes
when you are a
registered democrat you almost feel
obligated to have to support everything
that is on the ballot box of what all
democrats yeah and sometimes when you're
a republican you find kind of feel like
obligated to say
okay yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
right i have to agree with everything
i think what is starting to happen is
people are starting to say dude forget
about being a democrat or a republican
this [ __ ] just doesn't make any sense we
got to open up the schools what the hell
are we doing here
what are we doing here staying loyal to
a political party let's open the damn
schools and it's starting to happen
tomorrow well
i i i'm very very emotional and fired up
about this topic because
here's one thing we learned over the
past 14 years is just how powerful
teachers unions are
and it's extremely political and they
held cities hostage and i'm still
very very annoyed at them i don't think
an industry has taken a hit more than
the teachers industry educators in
general over the past year because
here's what happens because of these
greedy evil
union leaders for the teachers
associations it paints all of them in
that same broad brush i look at teachers
completely
different and i say this with my
daughter being a teacher
she graduated from pepperdine got a job
in a public school
was doing fine i don't want her joining
the la county
unified school district teachers union i
don't want her to do it and thank god
she got a great job at cavalry christian
which is one of the top
pub or private schools in all of la in
the palisades awesome i know it's a cool
this is one this is recent
yes phenomenal that's great good i know
we had a huge celebration for it was she
happy
oh my god she's ecstatic plus she's
starting the soccer program for him too
so i'm she's still doing the diving or
noticing so this is my older daughter
oh pepperdine yeah you got it got it
okay so i'm just grateful she's not in
the teachers union
and last week i had to go drop dash had
left his violin at home i had to go drop
it off at school
i couldn't even get in they go for like
two hours a day four days a week it's
the careers
violence he's violin he's a skateboarder
when that guy is on the cover of a gq
magazine you're not going to say we knew
when it was 11 years old yeah we knew
him
dash is a stud and a half so i couldn't
even get into school i had a literally i
standing right outside the door of the
office i had to call them on the phone
and saying can i come in and drop for
the sake of california i can't just say
that's a california thing that's
everywhere that's texas and florida even
in here
i can't no i can't if i go to school
they don't let me on campus when i'm
taking this okay when i'm touring
schools right now florida they don't
let you toward the schools until
applications been submitted until
they're considering
then they're allowing you so i can't say
that's california that's everywhere yeah
that makes sense that is pretty much
everywhere that's taking place by the
way something very weird happened
would you see it with the uc schools and
sats did you see that yeah they're
dropping him i thought that's kind of
weird and i'm curious to know what you
think about this so
university of california will no longer
consider s.a.t and act scores
this is a new york times story they will
no longer taken into account an
admissions or scholarship decisions for
its system for of 10 of 10 schools
which include some of the nation's most
sought after campuses in accordance with
a settlement
and a lawsuit brought by students the
settlement announced on friday signals
the end of a lengthy legal debate over
whether the university of california
system should use standardized tests
which students of color and those with
disabilities
have said that puts them at a
disadvantage some 225 000 undergrad
students
attend university california schools and
the settlement this week makes the
system the largest and best known
american institution
of higher education to distance itself
from the use of two major standardized
tests
and that's sats and acc yeah understand
that there's so much pressure on these
kids right now getting into the right
college is just
unbelievable so you're for this you
agree with you know what here's the
thing if you were gonna test really high
on these uh it's a bad it's really bad
news because that's
that's a golden ticket if you score what
a 34 on your sats you're in anywhere you
want to go basically so
i think it's unfortunate for the kids
that can prepare for these specific
tests
but it might 34 on saturday
go back to the university of miami and
start partying um
so ucla dropped them this past year
because of covid and
it completely changed the playing field
right it just opened up so many people
more people to have the opportunity to
get in there so
i i don't know it's but it's the way
we've been doing it for so long
and it's going to take a few years for
this to shake out and just see what the
effect what do you think about it what
do you think about it so i guess my
question is what are they using to judge
uh applicants just your gpa and your
resume well that and then what yes your
resume what kind of programs you've been
i don't know about that listen i mean i
get it i get the fact that there's a lot
of pressure to do that but dude
if you can't handle the pressure of
going into college how the hell are you
going to handle the pressure of real
life
what kind of pressure there's in real
life are you kidding me hey you got a
baby you got the pressure
having to put food on the table that's
real life pressure if
you want to get a job and there's a
deadline to it you can this is too much
pressure
isn't college supposed to like prepare
you for real life pressure
what's more pressure being married with
kids or going to college honestly
married with kids is way more pressure
than going to college so for me
i uh i don't know if i like this and i
got three kids one on the way so for me
i kind of want the kid listen
you ain't got a good essay to you you
got a good act guess what maybe you're
not good enough for that school
maybe maybe you got to go a different
route yeah but now if we don't find out
and you go to school it takes me four
years to realize we wasted money going
into college
i i don't think this is a race thing
what race
what does this have to do with race if
this is a race thing why are so many
asians killing it in school
if this is truly a race thing if you go
look at the greats in school
with with nationalities go look at how
persians do in school
honestly go look at our persons doing
school some of the best students
go look at how asians do in school
they're not american they're not white
this is not a race thing
this is the kind of stuff that's getting
a little bit pathetic when they're
talking about hey
it's because of race we have to drop a
ct and sat no it's not because of race
it's because it's tough and there's a
lot of pressure to getting an sat score
i got a real low sat score okay guess
what i realized it's probably not the
route for me i went into the military
that's not discrimination i sucked i
didn't pay attention in school i was
lazy
am i gonna say it's the school system's
fault no it's my fault i didn't
i didn't stay disciplined i lifted
weights instead i went and hung out
instead i want to sold hats instead i
saw beanies instead
i sold baseball cards instead i went in
the military two and a half years later
i got out and i went into sales the rest
is history so for me
to to it's like it's like the whole
thing with boot camp right boot camp is
too much pressure it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be a little bit tough
you're supposed to have a little bit of
a hurdle to go to the next level of a
school
if that's not the case then what becomes
special about going into the ucla system
morale graduated from ucla okay she
graduated ucla i think her gpa was like
4.5 4.6 when she went into ucla
you know to me when i see moral you know
what i think about i'm like
salute when she was she got her a
bachelor's degree then she want to got
her mba
guess what that's because you paid a
price when you were going in high school
others were partying
you were paying attention in class you
get a salute to getting into ucla now
you're telling me a girl
who busted or tailed to get into ucla
maybe got a scholarship for grace that
she had
parents didn't have to fork up you know
quarter of a million dollars now we have
to make her the same as another person
that didn't get good grades
didn't fight for the sat didn't fight
for acts they're at the same level i
don't see them being at the same level
yeah what's wrong with being competitive
for these kids
i don't see a challenge brother i think
we need that i think we have to
depensify
the next generation and we're producing
too many pansies if we go like this
225 000 undergrads biggest
so this to me is absolutely pathetic i
don't i'm sure you disagree give me this
right let me just give you a different
perspective i think i think you are
right that
that they shouldn't just do away with
this but at the same time
the ac tiers of the s.a.t is not an
indication
indicator that you're going to be
successful i know a lot of people that
crush their ever say
no no it's different perspective yeah
that crushed their sat they got a 1400
or they got a 32 whatever the numbers
are
and they can't interact with other human
beings and they can't sell stuff
and they don't have a business acumen or
they don't have that mark zuckerberg
they can't they can't network there's
different strokes for different folks is
ultimately the point
but i don't think it's fair to
unidentify very brilliant people
that would get a sixteen hundred dollar
1600 on the s8 so we're saying the same
thing we're not saying anything
ultimately it comes down to having an
overall resume that's impressive there's
got to be a standardized guidelines you
make it you make it you don't you don't
it's all good
go to a different place it's all gray
without something that's a little bit
black and white about test scores
so seriously you'll never know what
they're using as criteria to let people
in
and if you get rejected they'll never
give you an answer yeah it's like saying
well you know moving forward military
shouldn't look at weight
to get into the military they shouldn't
look at being flat-footed they shouldn't
look at
you're not having 20 20 vision they
shouldn't look at any of that stuff no
you should
you should that's part of going into the
military no no but you're discriminating
against heavy people
you should there are some things like
when the when in in sports scene when
antoine walker
didn't get his bonus because he put on
80 pounds
and the celtics discriminated against
him for his weight
you're supposed to do that what am i
supposed to do how are you going to run
and last and play 35 minutes and i'm
paying you 15 million a year 12 million
here
i met antoine walker nice guy we sat
down had a cigar to get a phenomenal
conversation he now represents
morgan stanley and he's trying to help a
lot of athletes not lose a lot of his
money i think he made 130 million
dollars in his career doesn't have a
penny of it
doesn't have any it doesn't have any of
it so so i think there are
some areas i i am not qualified to do a
lot of things and they should
discriminate against me
i am not qualified to do a lot of jobs
and i'm glad they did that
against me not discriminate against my
ethnicity because i'm iranian or because
i'm a syrian or armenian or because
i'm not born in the states and any of
that stuff there are some jobs that i
simply don't qualify for
and that's totally fine and i these guys
are dropping their standards long term
i've never been a fan of low standards
but that's the direction they're going
okay
let's go to the next story i think we
kind of have to cover
israel palestine because we got a lot of
different comments and
uh we have to address this because it's
been
going even more and look here's the
reality of it no matter what position
you take with this
we've gotten so much i can't believe you
said this
i can't believe this is what you
supported look we're talking about it
again
a lot of people avoid topics like this
we're talking about it
if you don't like us talking about it
just don't watch this part it's totally
fine with us but we're talking about it
we're sharing with you our opinions
you're
probably not going to like what anything
someone says here you may not like him
me or adam but we're comfortable with it
israel palestinian conflict marks its
deadliest day as terror
scenes of terror unfold in gaza this is
a cnn story
israel bombed the house of hamas gaza
leader and
obliterated obliterated a family's home
in the deadliest day of the week
uh long conflicts uh so far according to
the data from palestinian health
ministering gaza and israel authorities
israeli defense idf said it had bombed
the house of yaha sinwar hamas leader
since 2017 on early sunday morning
idea spokesperson brigadier general
hidayah zilberman told local media that
sinoir
had been unhurt in the airstrike two
israeli strikes and gaza killed at least
43 palestinians including eight children
and
50 others most of whom were women and
children on sunday told gaza and
the total death climb to 197 including
58 children 34 women
since the beginning of the israeli air
strikes on gaza this week at least 1235
palestinians have been injured
with the number expected to rise the
health ministry said as paramedics
continue to carry out
search operations 10 israeli have been
killed by rockets
fired from gaza according to the idf i
can go on giving you more numbers about
what happened in 2014 gaza war with saw
more than 200
gazans killed during the fighting
approximately half of them civilians
including more than 550 children
according to the united nations report
look when you anytime you read these
articles
and you see children breaks your heart
any time when i was in iran and we saw
the war happening and
you you hear stories that such and such
friend of yours that you had is no
longer with you because a bomb was drawn
by iraq on their home
i mean what are you talking about it's
it's ridiculous when you're in it of
course it's
heart-wrenching but this while this is
taking place but why is it really going
on and why is it not stopping i think
that's the question i would want to
address today
i got a couple answers for that and i
think from the research i've done is the
right now that you've got
two leaders that have given up on the
idea of lasting peace
so you got netanyahu and you got the
leader of hamas or you know palestine
that that
the only thing they can go for now is
total victory because they give it up on
the idea that there can be peace so
that's why it's going on
and you know what you have to just look
at it this way i don't trust hamas when
they're talking about some of the
numbers and everything like this because
their history is
they put civilians where the bombs are
where the missiles are
where the things that israel is
attacking they load it up
with civilians and children they don't
care
and the other thing too is israel is
warning them often times
when the bombs are coming to high target
areas they're giving them the
opportunity to clear out a little bit so
um that's part of the reason there's so
many children that are dying
so many civilians that are dying is
because that's part of their strategy
to put civilians there where they know
the airstrikes are coming
so um it's unfortunate it's the worst
fighting since 2014.
there's more airstrikes this morning
that have been coming in you know so the
thing has not leveled off at all
and it's it's dangerous and i think the
united states has to play a pretty key
role in where this
you know eventually goes and how it can
simmer down so i
uh this past weekend i um went to my
friend's house my friend orr he lives
here
in uh in delray oren or or
like gold and uh his parents
were in town from israel they lived just
outside of tel aviv
and i haven't seen his parents since
ironically 2014 when i was in israel for
orr's wedding so i'm talking to the
parents i was with my mom we were all
catching up
it was a family barbecue it was his
daughter's fourth birthday we had a nice
time and the father his name is eric
i said dude what is going on here like
let me hear it from your perspective you
got out how did you even get out like
meaning
he goes we flew out the day the fighting
started ironically enough
so he's been out been watching all this
and i said break this down for me
of what's going on and here's a couple
of things that we discussed so number
one
i think it's important to understand
this is not a religious war this isn't
like you're jewish i'll kill you uh
you're arabic you're muslim i'll kill
you this is a pure
land situation and people say well this
fighting goes back
thousands and thousands of years well
it's actually not true
it actually just goes back a couple
hundred years because this happened with
the ottoman empire
in the uh 18 18 19th century right
before world war one
and then the british empire they came in
and they were divvying up the land
and they promised this have promised
muslim christian
muslim jewish ultimately what happened
was
in 1947 israel became a state in 1948
they gave them their land and there was
a four there was a full-on war
and israel luckily for them they won the
war in 1948 they won the six day war in
1967 they won the other one
like what happens in war you [ __ ]
take you won the war you take the land
and essentially what has happened is
every so often there's been
deals that they've tried to cut and
israel has given
there's been i actually saw this on
prager university pretty
trusted source i would say they did a
expose on this they said
israel has tried to make peace and
compromise and they've given them 95
of the land and every time without fail
uh the plo whether under yasser arafat
or the hamas has rejected the deal
so ultimately there's a couple different
angles here
in israel there's definitely two
factions there's the bibi netanyahu
who's basically fighting for his
political life and
is an instigator of sorts and then
there's more the liberal side of israel
that they would like to coexist but then
there's parts of
hamas or palestine where they genuinely
just want to have a nice life to raise
their kids and live in peace
and they have a major bone to pick with
israel that they're
not allowing them to live their best
life and then there's the people who are
all they see is red and israel doesn't
have a right to exist
and uh they it's something called the
three nose no they don't have a right to
exist no they don't have a right to the
land
no they don't have the uh the right to
live in peace
and if it's yes exactly with that
mentality how are you supposed to
coexist
with someone that doesn't have believe
in your right to exist doesn't believe
that it's your land
israel is not going anywhere they've won
every single war they've given up land
they've given up the golan heights
they've given up the sinai peninsula
they've given up atlanta on the jordan
side of the river
and there's not there's no agreement
that some palestinians will ever agree
to unless israel leaves
the land and which they're not going to
do so
thank god that at least israel has this
iron dome situation going on
because can you imagine if someone's
firing 5 000 rockets and they all hit
civilians
so because they have this amazing
technology and they're
basically shooting down 90 95 percent of
missiles
which means dozens of missiles still
land on
innocent people um could you imagine
what would be happening in israel if
those missiles actually did
well they would have ended the war a lot
quicker probably but i will say i will
say one thing
and it sounds like i'm defending israel
and obviously i'm a little biased here
being jewish and have family in israel i
will say that
on one of the holiest days of ramadan um
there's the there's the um dome of the
rock
um bibi netanyahu set troops in
and dismantled muslims
praying near the dome of the rock in
east jerusalem
on ramadan one of the holy like so even
him my
my friend's dad who was like this is
unacceptable you this is ridiculous you
can't do this this is the
holiest day of year for the muslims this
is [ __ ]
so you're talking about an israeli who
is basically saying bibi netanyahu
what the hell are you thinking so it's
it's
such a gray area there's no black and
white here but
the last thing that i'll say is this and
i'll turn it over to you pbd
he did say the one difference between
israelis
and a certain portion of uh
hamas palestinians what do you call it
is the respect for life
there's no israeli suicide bombers there
are a lot of people in
that world that basically believe in
giving up their life and don't have a
respect for life
and are willing to blow themselves up
and what type of person is willing to do
that
ask yourself that question who's willing
to just blow themselves up
for a cause and it's not religious it's
socio-economic it's land
it's political and that was his biggest
takeaway even though he was defending by
the way very good commentary adam that
was very helpful and the way you did it
i appreciate that the way you explained
both sides i will say i'll take a
complete different angle on this here's
my angle on this
just on august 31st august 30th a guy
you guys may know his name is jared
kushner took a flight from
israel to uae crossing palestinian you
know
and trump had folks from palestine and
you know netanyahu there renegotiating
working together
what happened that was just eight months
ago nine months ago august 31st and
everybody this is ridiculous 25 years
can't believe trump this temperamental
guy was able to unify everybody
by the way again that's august 31st of
2020.
fast forward where we are today the the
two
going back and forth obviously there's
deep rooted issues you just kind of told
the history of where it's at and what
netanyahu did and what others did
here's my biggest concern so biden calls
netanyahu
and biden calls the leader of palestine
hamas he has a conversation with them
right phone call
with them when a phone call is being
made
by the most important man in the world
who is the president of the united
states
and they blow you off guess what that
means you have no influence
you're a nobody who blew up biden calls
netanyahu and palestine saying stop it
stop doing what you're doing neither one
of them listen to them
what does that tell you there is no
influence what do you think the phone
calls sounded like
i think it's i understand what you guys
are going through i think it's good you
guys need to stop it this is not good
people are dying children are dying
they're like uh
okay bye what are you talking about
fasfa would think about the phone call
of the guy that was the most hated man
in the world just about a year ago
let's say if that was happening today
trump made the phone call what is trump
going to say
i just want to let you know if i hear
one more rocket going i swear to god
you're gonna get 25 sanction put on you
for six months
do it i dare you go ahead go ahead and
do it i dare you okay okay okay mr
president we don't want to go to that
situation and we're not saying this to
you we're just saying
no no do it again go ahead and do it
again that is the kind of stuff
in moments like this where you realize
and you miss a guy
who actually had a backbone and people
feared him who actually had the
negotiation ability to challenge us
god knows there was a lot of other
things that he was doing that was
pissing a lot of people off and
creating a lot of unnecessary uh what's
the word i'm looking for
tension that was not not needed right
but fast forward
if trump made that phone call today that
would have happened here's the other
question i got for you
here's the other question i got for you
how instrumental was jared kushner in
this entire deal
how very much so by the way kushner is
not a republican people think he's a
republican he's not a republican he's an
independent at best
is what kushner is he's probably a
democrat his brother and his wife are
certainly a democrat
what i'm saying is he's not a republican
he is not a republican he's just
following trump
he's a you know he's he's a guy that
gets things done
that's kushner goes from real estate to
all of a sudden negotiating
a deal between israel and palace like
who are you like you think it's just a
real estate transaction the guy and he
doesn't even want the recognition right
so here's my question for you follow up
to what you just said hey
mr biden president biden this matters to
you a lot phenomenal thank you for being
such a man that cares about what's going
on in palestine and uh
and israel if it matters so much to you
have you made the phone call to a guy
named donald
and a man named jared who actually were
able to negotiate a piece
have you if you care about all these
people that are getting killed and are
being bombed
have you made that phone call to say hey
donald what should we do here hey jared
what did you do here this is not about
ego here this is if people's lives
really matter guess who you call you
call your ex
you call the husband of your wife that
you were with even though you can't
stand this guy say listen
my kids are living with your kids we got
a problem going out listen you and i
don't like each other i fully get it but
in this situation we both like our kids
yes or no perfect
what do we need to do in this situation
here because one of your kids got caught
smoking weed and my kids thinking about
doing the same thing as well
they were only 13 14 years old you and i
need to have a sit down together
this is when you realize who's a true
diplomat
negotiator this is when you realize
who's a real ambassador this is when you
realize who's a true statement that
cares
about the lives of people and if you
truly do it's not a phone call to
netanyahu and it's not a phone call to
them
it's a phone call too kind of donald
trump it's a phone call to a guy named
uh jared kushner fyi i want you to
visualize this
who wins in this situation let me paint
a picture and i got to go because
caroline's here telling me i got to go
i want to paint a picture to you next
week today's what today's thursday what
is today
today's tuesday this week what day uc
on friday or thursday biden on stage
with kushner and trump and kamala
hear me out on stage they get up and
they say
following statement folks we may
disagree
on god knows how many different things
but if there's one thing we agree on
is we don't like to see the violence
that's taking place in israel and
palestine right now
president trump and president biden and
i were on the same page
to have to stop this if you're watching
this right now netanyahu and palestine
this needs to stop
or else dot dot dot dot we're asking for
the support
because this matters that much if that
took place this week
who wins you're smiling because you're
actually seeing it if that took place
this week
the world would win the world wins but
on a serious note who actually wins
bidenwood biden wins not trump yes if
biden makes that call
biden wins and the world's going to say
he would look like a true diplomat but
do you think it will happen no
and that's why i'm still because the
place where all of this stuff
that's going on in the israelites
palestine all of this stuff that's going
on in israel and palestine could be
solved if the leaders truly cared about
this make the damn phone call to the
guys that were able to broker this deal
because they get the credit for this let
me say one thing just to wrap this up
and then we gotta go so i asked my
friend's dad
uh about his take and i said
give me uh the perspective on trump in
israel he goes oh no make no doubt
trump was very good for israel very good
but he was bad for the rest of the world
this is what he's saying and he goes but
i'll tell you one more thing
the arabs they only respond to strength
they only respond to strength there you
go they fear trump
they do not fear biden of course so this
goes back to initial another point that
you made
if you're on the democrat you just kind
of check all the democrat box
if you're a republican you you check all
the republican boxes there's something
amazing just being independent and a
free thinker and saying you know what
trump actually did a good job on israel
so i do
i would
yeah hey bottom line for me hey let's
have this podcast solve world peace
we can do it yeah all right that was
comments by the way if somebody's
watching this
we're going to put kai are we going to
cut this last part off with short clip
for palestine
if you agree with this okay if you agree
with this i want you to share this on
twitter maybe create a short clip
that's two minutes and 20 seconds i want
you to if i post it on twitter i want
you to retweet it send it to anybody and
everybody believe it or not people at
the white house
are paying close attention i guarantee
you someone's going to see this and say
what do you think about this if it
really matters let's do something about
it anyways we got to go
had a really good point today's quiet
test is one of my favorite one we've
done a long time had a really good time
about this a lot of good topics
energy was high gang if you enjoyed it
press the subscribe button and we will
do this again
thursday i believe with tom ellsworth
take care everybody bye bye bye bye
you